prison' mans à perpétuité alors je ne
veux pas le voir mourir dans une prison
américaine
et je crois que c'est le sort qui
l'attend sm je suis venu ici pour
essayer de plonger à la limite de mes
capacités
je n'aime pas le froid c'est un défi en
quelque sorte
essayez de plonger dans l'eau glacée des
eaux la vache
ce type qui a battu le record du monde
il a fait une autre plongée à 75 m je
dois plongé à 76 3 2 à départ
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités en plateau et nos reporters sur
le terrain
voici les grands titres de l'actualité
de ce lundi 9 mars
l'épidémie de corona virus continue de
se propager en france quatre nouveaux
décès portant le total à 25 morts et
plus de mille 400 cas confirmés dont on
l'apprend l'instant le ministre de la
culture francs crier de faire la menace
d'une pandémie est devenu très réelles
selon l' oms qui indique néanmoins que
plus de 70% des personnes malades en
chine ont guéri sur le plan de
l'économie les marchés ont accusé
aujourd'hui des plongeons digne de la
crise de 2008
le président turc recep tayyip erdogan
demande à l'otan son soutien concret
dans le conflit en syrie lors d'une
visite à bruxelles aujourd'hui les
négociations se tiennent en ce moment
même entre l'europe et la turquie qui a
décidé d'ouvrir dont ses frontières avec
la grèce à plusieurs milliers de
réfugiés
[Musique]
en afghanistan l'organisation état
islamique revendique une double
explosion à kaboul au lendemain de la
signature d'un accord de paix avec les
talibans
attentat qui a eu lieu ce matin pendant
les cérémonies d'investiture
présidentielle concurrents tous deux
responsables disent endosser la fonction
de président la france se hisse à la
troisième place du classement des pays
exportateurs d'armes l'hexagone
représente 7 9% du marché mondial un
record depuis 1990 aux deux premières
places les états unis et la russie
le procès des époux fillon ont jugé pour
des soupçons d'emploi fictif entre dans
sa dernière ligne droite ce lundi c'est
l'omission de la déclaration à la haute
autorité de transparence de la vie
publique d'une partie de son patrimoine
ou de ses intérêts qui est examinée
l'ex premier ministre qui plaide
l'erreur honnête
[Musique]
le coronavirus continue donc sa
propagation avec plus de cent dix mille
personnes contaminées dans le monde et
deux premiers décès en allemagne
chypre à son tour touchée aujourd'hui
tous les pays de l'union européenne sont
concernés 150 quinze mille pardons
personnes touchées au total et les
mesures pour contrer l'épidémie se
multiplient en france donc le ministère
annonce quatre nouveaux décès portant le
total à 25 et 1412 qu'a confirmé le
ministre de la culture france reste ra
été testés positifs mais se dit en forme
d'après son cabinet plus tôt dans la
journée la ministre des sports a
souligné l'importance du huis clos dans
les événements sportifs tout en
rappelant l'interdiction des
rassemblements de plus de 1000 personnes
on écoute j'ai roussel aumont directeur
général de la santé ce jour à 15h selon
santé publique france nous avons 1412
cas confirmés soit 286 de plus qui hier
nous avons aujourd'hui un nouveau
regroupement de cas c'est en corse à
ajaccio et la corse signal 38 cas nous
avons une évolution probablement
inéluctable difficilement évitable vers
une épidémie mais il demeure de
nombreuses incertitudes d'abord sur le
comportement du virus et surtout soit
l'impact des mesures barrières et
individuelle et collective que nous
mettons en place plus de 1000 tests sont
réalisés par jour avec des capacités
largement supérieur de laboratoire le
plan bleu a été activé au plan national
dans tous les établissements
médico-sociaux je le rappelle ce soir la
très grande majorité des formes de la
maladie sont bénignes
ainsi les agences régionales de santé
sont en mesure de décider en lien avec
les professionnels de santé de ville qui
sont des acteurs clés un suivi à
domicile des personnes ne présentant pas
de forme sévère de la maladie est prêt
les mesures prises par le gouvernement
vendredi aujourd'hui mais ne mettront a
pris la parole le président de la
république souhaite davantage de
coordination au niveau européen les 27
dirigeants participeront demain
probablement l'après midi à une
visioconférence
je souhaite qu'on ait plus de
coordination européenne et
internationale et j'annoncerai d
active dès cet après midi en la matière
il est important que nous ayons une
réponse qui correspondent à la nature du
risque vu par les scientifiques est
telle qu'ils nous informent que cette
réponse permettent de freiner l'épidémie
est ce que nous sommes en train de faire
et qu'elle soit toujours guidé par la
science est proportionné très parmi les
nouveaux cas de coronavirus en france
cinq députés et le patron des dp il est
difficile pour les français de se
positionner doivent-ils avoir peur du
coronavirus ou au contraire ne pas céder
à la panique
gerald kean sec médecin urgentiste
chroniqueur également pour lui s'il y a
un quiétude c'est à cause de la
surmédiatisation et les mesures
actuellement qui sont prises qui sont
d'ordre justification sanitaire mais qui
ont des conséquences économiques et
politiques même en l âpreté élections
municipales en tant que médecin et je
suis pas le seul à le penser on a
vraiment l'impression qu'on en fait
énormément sur le court 1 à virus
oui c'est un virus qui va tuer qui va
tuer les personnes les plus fragiles
mais j'allais dire comme la grippe
chaque année dans l'indifférence
générale l indifférence générale vous
avez dix mille morts par an en plein pic
d'épidémie fait 170 morts par jour est
ce qu'on en fait le décompte est ce
qu'on prend toutes ces mesures les
autres année alors que généralement on
dénonce justement le manque de moyens à
l'hôpital par exemple noura pourquoi
cette année il ya ce lot de mesures il
ya ce décompte anxiogène on peut se
poser on peut se poser la question et
puis surtout nous ce qui nous inquiète
c'est les phénomènes de panique de
psychose générale d'hystérie collective
et il faudrait pas qu'on arrive à les
troubles à l'ordre public qui serait
plus embêtant que coronavirus finalement
l europe a passé aujourd'hui le cap des
500 décès liés aux coronavirus avec 97
nouveaux morts en 24 heures en italie le
pays
deuxième foyer dans le monde l'épidémie
met en place des mesures drastiques 15
millions d'habitants sont en quarantaine
une mesure de confinement prévu jusqu'au
3 avril elle concerne une vaste zone
dans le nord du pays
il s'agit là d'une mesure inédite en
europe les précisions avec leila sarah
fait et clément spectacle
des supermarchés pris d'assaut faso
coronavirus en zone rouge italienne les
habitants vivent tant bien que mal au
rythme de la quarantaine rome a placé
sous cloche une grande partie du nord de
l'italie pour tenter de contenir
l'épidémie
les rues sont désertes les gares et les
aéroports sont vides
la population s'est résigné à vivre au
ralenti nous avons des mesures corée
pour maintenir la sécurité autant que
possible nous allons donc de l'avant de
manière responsable
on espère on en sortir le plus tôt
possible la vie a déjà bien changé à pia
senza depuis ce matin car le décret
gouvernemental a déjà modifié les
habitudes des citoyens
il ya moins de monde les bars on en vend
des raretés et queens à des primes s'ils
sont assis d'un grand changement
modifications fictive mais tout le monde
ne partage pas cette vision depuis
dimanche des mutineries ont éclaté dans
les prisons du pays
en cause les mesures contre la
propagation du virus comme l'arrêt des
visites simorre déjà à modène et ce
lundi à milan la famille des détenus en
est venu aux mains avec les forces de
police
cela dépend de plein de choses je suis
convaincu que le virus est partout en
italie les restrictions appliquées
uniquement à milan me sont donc stupide
at jeu c'est quelqu'un voyage c'est
probablement sans mauvaise intention
il ne semble donc improbable que cette
personne se met en danger
mounis khadidja l'épidémie provoque
aussi l'exode de nombreux habitants pour
rejoindre d'autres régions d'italie
le gouvernement cherche à rassurer pour
éviter que la situation n'empire
il n'y a pas de régions d'italie qui
soit complètement
il ya des parties de l'italie où le
virus circule actuellement - mais le
fait que le virus circule dépend de
notre comportement
la mesure touche le poumon économique de
l'italie et sa capitale milan où vivent
plus de 15 millions d'habitants
les restrictions drastiques
s'appliqueront au moins jusqu'au 3 avril
prochain et pour en parler nous sommes
avec un météorite alberti rédacteur en
chef du média putsch bonsoir météo
gisèle bercy merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors le nombre
des cas positifs a grimpé en italie en
9172 calmes et parmi eux il faut le
préciser parce qu'elle parle souvent des
bonnes nouvelles
en tout cas on l'est souligne pas assez
724 personnes quand même considéré comme
guéri
vous les journalistes italiens quel est
votre regard sur ce climat
aujourd'hui est ce qu'on en fait trop ou
yens vraie psychose qui s'installe juste
titre maison qui a effectivement une
convention de la part de la population
de l'essence que on savait art combien
aussi votre reportage la craie les gens
prendre de nouvelles habitudes et
effectivement il reçoit les implications
aussi par exemple du maire de milan qui
a invité justement à changer de style de
vie et ce n'est pas évident parce que
imaginez une ville comme paris parce que
si on prend dans paris intra muros un
peu la même dimension de de celle de
milan qui a tout d'un coup doit ralentir
et toi éviter de voir ses habitants
s'est rencontré et pour plein de raisons
donc les personnes
au téléphone et via skype et via les
autres réseaux sociaux m'ont confirmé
que bon on s'adapte notamment par
exemple j'ai eu aussi beaucoup de
journalistes qui ont commencé à
travailler un télétravail là où les
rédactions pouvait effectivement se
permettre parce que on parle par exemple
de la presse écrite
beaucoup ont commencé à travailler
depuis chez eux et c'est la montre l'un
des aspects de cette cette crise qui
impacte fortement sur la vie d'un pays
parce que on pense pas peut-être que
s'il n'y a pas de journalistes qui font
leur travail sur le terrain on peut pas
avoir les informations mais en même
temps vous avez effectivement montré
aussi des images des prisons italiennes
il faut dire qu'il peint ces zones qui
sont bloqués il y aussi la justice qui
est à l'arrêt et qui ne fonctionne pas
et donc on peut pas assurer les trois
qui sont les droits démocratiques qu'on
peut qu'on est très bien sûr aussi en
france et puis naturellement il ya la
santé grave grave grab occupation parce
que le système est où est à un niveau de
l'explosion
il y a des médecins qui ont été rappelés
de l'état n'avait traité
on a permis aussi à des étudiants en
médecine dernière à la dernière mais de
de rentrer un petit peu un service et
bascule notamment les les divisions de
réanimation ou de thérapie intensive
sont extrêmement sous pression et on
risque dans certains hôpitaux
lorsqu'on me dit je n'ai pas la
possibilité d'aller constater moi-même
donc il faut les prendre avec les
pincettes mais on commence sa fin c'est
comment on peut choisir entre ceux qui
en plus de chance le septième temps se
façonner ce qui m'a longs mois et ça
c'est très préoccupant matière jose
alberti joseph et comptait l'avouer à
demi-mot certains petits peut-être
dysfonctionnements qui ont fait que ce
cette épidémie s'est propagé à cette vie
c'est ce que ça vous semble juste cette
ce diagnostic ou c'est peut-être un peu
dur pour l'italie parce que pour
l'instant on est au début en france mais
on peut peut-être suivre la même voie
enfin quelle est votre vision là dessus
je pense qu'il y avait eu
malheureusement beaucoup d'erreurs
surtout au début de cette crise parce
que ils ont le gouvernement italien a
bel et des questions qui étaient qui
relevaient de la politique et de
l'avenir de la confrontation politique
avec les forces d'opposition qui sont
globalement de forces de droite et ils
ont occupé accusé les oppositions de
vouloir faire du souverainisme déboulé
et vouloir discriminer des personnes en
fonction de leurs origines asiatiques ou
chinoises mais en réalité on a constaté
que compte par exemple matteo salvini où
les présidents des régions du nord de
l'italie qui sont toutes d'expression de
la ligue qui demandaient des
quarantaines lui demander des mesures de
confinement est bien le gouvernement a
répondu que c'était comment dire de la
xénophobie et du souverainisme alors que
par exemple il ya aussi le président de
la région toscane qui a refusé de
prévoir des quarantaines pour environ
2000 personnes d'origine chinoise qui
sont rentrés du nouvel an chinois à côté
de florence parce que à prato cette
ville à côté de florence justement il y
a une forte communauté chinoise et les
personnes de cette communauté qui se
sont auto isolé pouvoir éviter
éventuellement d'être un de contaminer
d'autres d'autres personnes écrit on a
vu que il y avait eu moins des cadres
des contaminations dans cette zone
c'est là pour dire que personne voulait
stigmatiser lui me une partie de la
population mais on est arrivé exactement
à cette chose parce que vous savez que
je lisais dans la presse italienne
aujourd'hui que les ya même des familles
qui résident dans le sud de l'italie qui
ont requis lyonnais monde ira se sont
aimés remis avec allure
membres leurs cousins leur cynisme et
parents qui sont revenus au pays depuis
le nord de l'italie
et donc on se retrouve dans une
situation publique où on n'a pas à
utiliser des filtres depuis l'extérieur
et maintenant les italiens se sont un
peu comment dire infiltrés intrus même
il y a on utilise des frontières des
frontières régionales mais pourquoi
parfois peut-être on ne régule de
prendre le considéra sommes alors on le
rappelle à on l'a dit 15 millions
d'italiens confiné outre ces quarantaine
le gouvernement qui a annoncé
aujourd'hui la fermeture de toutes les
stations de ski du pays c'est évidemment
terrible en or des conséquences sur la
santé publique on en parlait il ya
quelques instants il ya des terribles
conséquences sur l'économie est ce que
ça vous semble tenable cette situation
en italie
j'ai vu beaucoup de résilience
maintenant mais je sais pas combien de
temps ça va tenir un tour deux raisons
d'abord l'italie est fortement
interconnectés avec par exemple la
france mais aussi avec les autres pays
européens notamment l'allemagne
et si le poumon économique item bien
s'arrête il faut considérer qu'elle par
exemple il ya des gares françaises vient
de forte participation
les banques italiennes et si il y a par
exemple le monde du luxe qui s'arrête
parce que on n'a pas la possibilité de
produire des produits de luxe en italie
et qui sont comment dire après vendus
par des groupes français ça aussi ça va
impacter sur l'économie française
et puis il ya tout tout le reste qui est
de conduire vue qui fait partie de
l'économie italienne celle émise arrêté
bloqués imaginez paris qui n'a plus de
touristes pendant un mois au moins
je pense personnellement que on devait
arriver avant à ces mesures de filtrage
de quarantaine de blocage peut être pu
être plus limité je ne suis pas
ça mais ce que je constate depuis puis
si à travers le média et les témoignages
que je reçois des mes amis et de ma
famille je suis préoccupé parce que je
ne sais pas combien de temps ça
autre aspect météo g7 bercy ça sera ma
dernière question vous l'avez évoqué
vous même tout à l'heure il ya eu des
émeutes en dans plusieurs établissements
pénitentiaires
les militants des droits de l'homme
avère que jusque monde un risque de
rébellion qui pourrait s'amplifier c'est
un problème pris au sérieux en italie
alors les italiens réagissent d'une
façon différente
hollande a parlé souvent quand il ya eu
les journaux bild il ya une inertie tude
un peu différente mais je pense que à
force de le d'arriver à destination des
difficultés surtout il faut pas oublier
que jusqu'à pas marrant moi pratiquement
les écoles resteront fermées certains
cadres du ministère de l'instruction par
ex ante up france de valider l'année
pour surtout les écoliers pourrait
quitter l'équipe perd aussi la mêlée
scolaire parce que c'est un coeur plus
difficile mais je pense que si on voit
par exemple l'élu les instants où noé
mais elles sont un danger je pense que
le sentiment général sera plutôt plutôt
négatif je dois dire en tout cas que ce
qu'on voit à l'italie devrait
effectivement être pris comme elle est
un exemple depuis paris et j'espère que
ça sera une occasion aussi pour coopérer
pour travailler ensemble pour anticiper
effectivement avec la l'extérieur sauf
est amis s'allient pour éviter que des
personnes ailleurs mieux rentrer puis ce
puissant pas tiré et puis j'espère que
quand il y aura le moment de la rectrice
qui demandent si rare de vous c'est
sérieux voilà merci beaucoup en tout cas
matteo jose alberti rédacteur en chef
plus immédiat foutu merci d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france et en
france donc la bourse de paris a accusé
aujourd'hui ça
chute sur une séance depuis près de 12
ans -8 39% à la fermeture selon bruno le
maire la croissance française a été
impactée par le coronavirus avec un
premier trimestre en demi-teinte
le ministre de l'économie et des
finances participer à une réunion
d'urgence ce matin il a évoqué les
secteurs en difficulté dont d'avoir les
premiers chiffres du trimestre 2020 qui
montrent que l'économie française
s'était bien redresser au premier mois
de janvier 2020 preuve que l'économie
française repose sur des bases stables
mais en revanche dès la mi-février a
fortiori début mars
nous voyons un impact très directe de
l'épidémie de qourna virus sur notre
économie
je donnerai nouvelles évaluations
chiffrées lors de la présentation des
prévisions du pacte de stabilité
c'est-à-dire le 15 avril
vous aurez une nouvelle prévision
chiffrée de croissance française mais je
le redis
l'impact se chiffrera en plusieurs
dixièmes de points de pib pour
l'économie française
si on regarde secteur par secteur on
revient que un certain nombre de
secteurs sont très durement touchée et
l'impact et violents pour ces secteurs
qui étaient présents ce matin je vous
donne quelques chiffres qui vont été
donnée par les professionnels il ya
quelques instants
c'est des baisses de chiffre d'affaires
de 60 % en moyenne pour les créateurs de
30 à 40% dans l'hôtellerie de 25% en
moyenne pour les restaurateurs et des
chiffres encore plus fort pour tout le
secteur de l'événementiel puisque les
des annulations se font aujourd'hui en
cascade dans ce secteur-là l'épidémie de
coronavirus aura un impact sévère sur
l'économie française qui se chiffrera en
plusieurs dixièmes de points de pib
durant l'année 2020 avec les craintes
allié au corona virus la chute du cours
des prix du pétrole
un plombé également le cac40 le pétrole
qui termine en baisse de 25% à new york
est à 31,13 pour dollars le baril des
cours qui ces fonds malgré les
négociations entre la russie et l'opep
l'organisation des pays exportateurs de
pétrole l'arabie saoudite décide de
baisser ses prix pour essayer de
relancer la demande la plus importante
réduction de ces prix pétroliers depuis
vingt ans et on fait le point sur ses
conséquences économiques notamment sur
le pétrole avec money hameau dès lors
depuis des semaines tout le monde ne
parle que de ça le coronavirus
représente une urgence de santé publique
mais aussi une menace pour la croissance
puisque la crise provoquée par
l'épidémie frappe de plein fouet
l'économie mondiale qui se dirige tout
droit vers une récession
les principales bourses d'asie essuient
une lourde perte
victime de la propagation du virus mais
aussi de l'effondrement du marché du
pétrole les cours de l'or noir qui ont
connu ce lundi leur pire chute depuis la
première guerre du golfe en 91 se sont
effondrées de plus de 30 % en asie une
crise due en partie au conflit entre la
russie et l'arabie saoudite deux des
trois plus gros producteurs mondiaux et
face à la chute de la consommation ces
derniers n'ont pas réussi à s'entendre
pour réduire leur production
une réunion de crise a eu lieu avec les
13 pays de l'organisation des pays
exportateurs de pétrole et moscou s'est
opposé à une nouvelle réduction d 1,5
million de barils par jour et a donc
décidé de faire cavalier seul et en
réponse à cela et bien ryad a déclenché
une véritable guerre des prix entraînant
la chute des cours du brut
alors pour vous donner une idée des
conséquences sur les coûts on est
actuellement à 35 dollars le baril de
pétrole contre 70 dollars juste avant
l'épidémie prenait la chine par exemple
qui est le premier consommateur de brut
mondial 14 % de la demande
soit 14 millions de barils par jour
l'europe n'est pas épargnée
l es mons du continent sont également en
chute libre et tout le monde ya droit lé
pays avec une économie fragile vont en
pâtir les premiers le venezuela
l'algérie l'iran ou encore le nigeria et
qui risque de basculer dans des crises
économiques et sociales à cause d'un
prix du brut et qui s'effondrent les
mesures saoudienne sur le prix du
pétrole pourrait donc avoir un rôle
crucial dans la crise économique
mondiale vers laquelle nous nous
dirigeons peut-être et pour en parler
nous sommes en direct depuis gainesville
en floride avec tom luongo économistes
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir bonsoir tob luongo merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france on
se rappelle un ce chiffre le pétrole qui
termine en baisse de 20 5% à new york 31
le baril le dollar pardon le baril est
ce que ce sont des chiffres qui vous
inquiète
cela dépend à qui on parle si on parle
des associations des sociétés
américaines alors oui elles sont très
inquiète toujours et préoccupé par le
prix du pétrole sauf les consommateurs
bien sûr qu'ils vont profiter de prix de
l'énergie bien plus bas pour les
consommateurs c'est bien pour les
exportateurs c'est mal et pour
l'économie j'ai envie de vous demander
en général il ya compté consommateurs
d'un côté bien sûr vous l'avez dit mai
l'économie en général est ce qu'elle
peut clairement pâtir de ces chiffres
inquiétants
tout à fait le problème avec une baisse
brutale des prix du pétrole c'est que le
marché sont structurées autour du prix
présent donc les contrats présents et
futurs sont basés sur ce prix et si la
marge baisse alors les contrats en
souffrait beaucoup de personnes perdent
beaucoup d'argent
le problème plus important c'est pour
les producteurs de pétrole et les
répercussions pour ces personnes qui ne
peuvent pas absorber beaucoup de dettes
les personnes qui lui les sociétés qui
ont beaucoup de dettes ne lui font pas
se permettre de continuer à vous de
continuer à produire avec ses prix cela
aura des répercussions sur les banques
qui ont prêté l'argent et cela mènera à
des effets de gaz 4 sur le marché c'est
ce que l'on commence à observer
aujourd'hui avec la baisse des actions
les personnes essayent de d'acheter de
l'or par exemple temps effectivement les
bourses qui termine en forte baisse 1
aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous en tant qu'économiste
vous avez de sérieuses inquiétudes on se
dirige tout droit vers une crise telle
qu'on l'a vécu en 2008
cette crise actuelle a dit james a des
racines qui remontent à il ya six mois
lorsque j'ai eu des problèmes
économiques à new york et la réserve
fédérale a dû commencer à intervenir
la réserve fédérale a commencé à
s'ingérer et à créer une sensation
forces de sécurité et nous commençons à
voir les conséquences de cela les
conditions sont présentes pour une
inflation globale de l'activité
économique
le prix des actifs baisse également les
dépassements en dix minutes et il nous
avions juste besoin d'un moment
charnière d'un catalysateur et il faut
considérer tout cela comme une
contraction massive des actions du
dollar et c'est la cause véritablement
ce problème et cela le coz depuis six
mois nous allons voir les répercussions
de cela à l'avenir même après la fin de
cette panique actuelle qui ne va sans
doute pas duré longtemps mais y aura
ensuite une deuxième problème comme nous
l'avons vu en 2008
en mars 2008 j'ai eu un premier problème
et puis à septembre
cela a eu des répercussions sur les
marchés subsidiaire et etc
merci en tout cas tom longo économistes
d'avoir été avec nous pour notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
restez avec nous donc quelques instants
nous parlerons de la rencontre à
bruxelles entre les dirigeants de
l'union européenne et le président turc
recep tayyip erdogan afin de tenter de
relancer le dialogue sur la crise
migratoire épi direction l'afghanistan
plongé dans une crise institutionnelle
alors que le chef de l'état ashraf ghani
et son rival abdullah abdullah se
déclarent tous deux présidents
[Musique]
c'est le sentiment que vous avez eue
vous aussi ce besoin d'autonomie
oui complètement besoin d'autonomie
besoin de retourner à des choses plus
essentielles en fait est vraiment de
sentir qu'on n'est pas forcément un
poids pour la planète
il ya une idée derrière il ya une
philosophie aussi qu'on a vu la serre
les plantes poussent le fait de vivre
avec les plantes comme ça vraiment
commune comme une machine un organisme
pour faire partie de cet organisme
on a eu vraiment l'impression de se
construire en même temps qu'on vous
construisez cette maison en faisant
toutes ces rencontres et je pense que
ces gens de projets qui se fait pas tout
seul dans son coin on est dans un truc
vraiment de coopération de partage de
partage
l'hiver est la période à laquelle le
sahara rené est les palmiers des oasis
sont l'objet de récolte les gens
attendent l'événement le plus important
de l'année
le festival du désert mais cette
compétition est très dur
les principaux chameliers a passé
l'année à se préparer pour un marathon
éreintant
la veille de la course une forte tempête
de sable se lève faire face à la
puissance de la nature est un défi
permanent
[Musique]
20h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur rt france n'est
recep tayyip erdogan et à bruxelles en
ce moment il a donné une conférence de
presse commune avec le secrétaire
général de l'otan à enstone bergues
le président turc a insisté sur le
soutien total et sans condition que
l'organisation doit apporter à ankara on
écoute le président turc
nous sommes le seul pays de l'otan qui
luttent contre tech homme à homme et qui
a sacrifié défi nous accueillons
également 3,7 millions de réfugiés
syriens
à l'avenir nous voulons un soutien
concret de nos alliés la turquie mène ce
combat seul jusqu'à présent au prix de
grands sacrifices l'otan vit une période
charnière elle devrait faire la preuve
d'une solidarité profonde à écouter à
présent jens stoltenberg le secrétaire
général de l'otan qui affirme le soutien
des pays de l'organisation et son envie
de trouver d'autres moyens de le faire
nous sommes conscients que la turquie
supporter une charge importante mais il
faut trouver des termes des solutions
durables à sceptre crise
je suis très préoccupé par ce qui s'est
passé leur frontière turque récemment
les flux migratoires sont un défi qui
nécessite des solutions
j'accueille donc
dialogue entre la turquie et l'union
européenne et j'espère que l'on pourra
trouver un moyen d'avancer
l'otan continuera à jouer son rôle
les nuits seront déjà pour résoudre la
crise migratoire les alliés sont
également prêts à continuer à soutenir
la turquie et nous explorons d'autres
façons de le faire et le porte parole du
ministère allemand des affaires
étrangères s'est exprimé cet après-midi
les catégories qu'il ne laissera pas la
turquie faire du chantage à l'union
européenne écoute ce n'est pas notre
impression que la turquie ne veuille pas
d'autres soutiens de l'union européenne
bien au contraire nous avons
l'impression que la turquie est
intéressé par d'autres mesures de
soutien et des discussions ont lieu
aujourd'hui à bruxelles à ce sujet entre
le président turc et madame von der
leyen et nous sommes prêts à y
participer de manière constructive c'est
un soutien supplémentaire s'avère
nécessaire
en même temps il est clair que nous ne
nous laisserons pas faire de chantage
ce que nous recherchons c'est une
répartition équitable de la charge
la turquie fait beaucoup de choses et
nous sommes prêts à la soutenir mais
cela n'est possible qu ensemble dans le
cadre d'une coopération qui devrait
avoir lieu aujourd'hui à bruxelles
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir coque blanche
maison mère souffre avec nous
rencontrons l'a dit aujourd'hui entre le
président turc 1 et le secrétaire
général de l'otan r douanes qui appelle
donc l'otan un soutien concret qu'est ce
que ça signifie la turquie est un est un
membre de l'otan depuis depuis 68 ans
donc depuis très longtemps et sur le
territoire turc qui a des bases au temps
des bases américaines
la position de la turquie et stratégique
elle contrôle les droits du bosphore par
conséquent c'est un allié important de
l'otan et
évidemment monsieur erdogan comme on
pouvait s'y attendre la demande à
nouveau un soutien concret de l'otan il
a dans l'esprit sans doute quelque chose
qu'il est impossible de réaliser et de
lui donner qui serait une offre
l'établissement d'une no fly zone au
dessus de la région d'idlib de façon à
se protéger des bombardements du régime
syrien mais ce tout l'espace aérien de
la syrie étant contrôlé par la russie il
est tout à fait clair que les états unis
n'ont pas du tout envie de se trouver
confrontées à la russie par conséquent
cette demande qui n'a pas été formulée
de façon aussi précise mais c'est
probablement ce qu'il a en tête ne peut
pas être satisfaite et l'otan est une
alliance militaire
elle ne fait pas dans l'action
humanitaire que je sache
par conséquent il ne peut pas offrir
grand chose sauf un soutien moral par
ailleurs erdogan a choisi de suivre un
chemin particulier sur la syrie
puisqu'il n'a pas voulu entrer dans
l'alliance que diriger les américains il
a aussi monté d d d d d action avec des
groupes qui peut être avait été assez
proche de les islamistes ou mêmes de
l'état islamiste
il a voulu suivre un chemin très
particulier est finalement passé des
accords avec la russie pour être le
gardien des derniers rebelles et c'est
ce qui se passe avec la zone dite libre
et rebelle
quand les transporter des zones qui
étaient des autres de désescalade dans
la zone dite libre
ils sont maintenant quinze mille ou
20000 dans la zone dite libre
entouraient 3 millions de civils
et c'est cette soluce ce problème qui
devient maintenant très difficile à
résoudre et qui a été créée par
l'attitude très particulière de monsieur
erdogan qui en plus étaient surtout
intéressés par la réduction des kurdes
puisque les kurdes pour lui c'est
videmment l'ennemi potentiel absolue
dans la mesure où ils peuvent
revendiquer un jour un kurdistan
indépendant alors une rencontre à on l'a
dit avec les dirigeants de l'union
européenne en ce moment même très
attendu évidemment qu'est ce qu'on peut
en attendre
bah l'union européenne à des moyens
beaucoup plus diversifiée que l'otan
elle n'a pas de moyens militaires mais
elle a des moyens diverses et variées
d'abord un budget avec des fonds et
lorsque madame ursula von der leyen est
allé sur la frontière entre la grèce et
la turquie
jeudi dernier elle a promis 700 millions
d'euros à la grèce
mais on a dit aussi dans le même temps
que j'étais peut-être possible
d'augmenter les fonds qui avaient été
alloués à la turquie 6 6 milliards
d'euros pour s'occuper des 300 et
quelques 300 une idée des 3 millions
pardon de réfugiés qui se trouvent
actuellement en turquie
on a parlé d'une somme peut-être de 500
millions d'euros qui pourrait s'ajouter
aux 6 milliards décidé en 2016 qui n'ont
d'ailleurs pas été complètement
débourser puisque le taux d'engagement
et d' environ les deux tiers de cette
somme et le taux de déboursement
environs d'un tiers par conséquent ses
modalités la peuvent être discutés en ce
moment probablement entre monsieur
erdogan et madame ursula von der leyen
mais il est certain que madame von der
leyen comme monsieur comme le président
du conseil européen vont lui expliquer
qu'il n'est pas question de recevoir des
masses de réfugiés à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne que d'ailleurs on a
très bien
vu que ça avait un effet de en politique
intérieure immédiat qui était de faire
monter les parties les partis anti
européens dans les états membres et que
par conséquent ce n'est pas une
politique qui pourrait être suivi alors
le gouvernement allemand qui propose une
coalition de pays volontaires de l'union
européenne pour prendre en charge
jusqu'à 1500 migrants mineurs bloqués
sur les îles grecques ce premier pas
alors ça c'est une très bonne idée en
effet ce sont des enfants qui sont
d'ailleurs malades qui sont mineurs qui
sont isolées qui n'ont pas de parents
pas de famille et qui ont besoin d'être
prises en charge médicalement donc un
certain nombre de pays membres de
l'union européenne dont la france
d'ailleurs se sont déclarés volontaires
pour en prendre
en tout jusqu'à 1500 ça n'est pas
beaucoup mais comme vous le sujet c'est
un premier pas et je pense que de plus
en plus on va voir apparaître des images
de la zone dite libre qui est une zone
où est en train de se produire une des
plus grandes catastrophes humanitaires
qui se soit produit depuis longtemps je
ne suis pas sûr que les opinions
publiques un peu partout supporter ça a
très longtemps
il n'ya plus d'hôpitaux qui fonctionne
il n'y a plus de médicaments
il n'y a plus d'école qui fonctionne les
gens sont en train de mourir de faim les
familles sont disloqués beaucoup
d'enfants sont isolés et c'est une
catastrophe humanitaire
pure et simple et donc il va
probablement falloir le traité sous cet
aspect là l'union européenne a les
outils pour traiter d'une catastrophe
humanitaire
et peut-être pour acheminer à travers
des couloirs humanitaires des
médicaments et peut-être même des
médecins et on espère en tout cas ans
est en plein milieu d'une crise ans
quand même lié au corona virus merci en
tout cas claude blanche raison d'avoir
été avec nous les troupes américaines
commencent à se retirer d'afghanistan
alors qu'aujourd'hui un nouvel attentat
revendiqué par le groupe etat islamique
a visé le palais présidentiel à kaboul
deux explosions ont retenti au moment où
achraf gagner son opposant abdullah
abdullah a organisé des cérémonies
d'investiture concurrentes et détaillé
grégoire tossée
à
deux explosions en plein discours le
président sortant achraf rallye d'un
côté et son grand rival le chef de
l'exécutif
abdullah abdullah de l'autre se déclare
alors tous deux présidents deux
cérémonies qui ont lieu au sein du même
palais présidentiel nous avons vu des
attaques plus importantes
n'ayez pas peur et deux explosions ne
paniquez pas asseyez-vous lors de notre
campagne pour l'élection nous avions
promis au peuple que nous n'accepterions
aucun gouvernement résultant d'une
fraude et nous tenons notre promesse une
véritable cacophonie politique est un
événement qui plonge un peu plus
l'afghanistan dans une crise
institutionnelle qu'il ya près de six
mois
le scrutin présidentiel donne lieu à des
résultats incertains annoncé de manière
définitive bien plus tard au mois de
février après seize mille cinq cents
plaintes pour irrégularités
selon la commission électorale ashraf
ghani obtient 52 64 % des suffrages
son principal opposant abdullah abdullah
termine second ce dernier qualifié alors
les résultats de trahison nationale
l'attaqué terroriste de ce lundi est la
deuxième depuis l'accord entre les états
unis et les talibans signé le 29 février
un pacte qui prévoit entre autres le
retrait sous 14 mois des troupes
étrangères une situation politique
confuse analysées par le spécialiste du
moyen-orient
david rigoulet roze c'est le résultat
des élections qui est contesté donc on
retrouve une situation propre ou
similaire à celle de 2014 avec les mêmes
les mêmes protagonistes à savoir un
strap rani et abdullah abdullah
les deux ont décidé de faire
effectivement une cérémonie
d'investiture le paradoxe est que ça se
fait dans deux ailes différentes du même
palais présidentiel à kaboul donc c'est
assez paradoxal mais effectivement c'est
le signe des divisions profondes de
l'exécutif argan et ça n'augure rien de
bon par rapport à une étape ultérieure
qui était un
prévue dans le cadre de l'accord signé
avec les talibans entre les américains
et à libon à doha à savoir le dialogue
entre un terreau afghans qu'ils
demanderaient effectivement un exécutif
au moins homogène une crise qui
intervient alors que d'importants
pourparlers doivent avoir lieu ce mardi
entre les insurgés des autorités de
kaboul l'opposition et la société civile
jusqu'à ce jour les talibans refuse de
reconnaître la légitimité du
gouvernement afghan
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
emmanuel dupuy président de l'institut
prospective et sécurité en europe
bonsoir quesnel dupuis merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
avant le chef de l'état un les chefs
dirait sera ashraf ghani et abdullah
abdullah se déclarent tous les deux
présidents ont déjà commencé possible on
a du mal à nous se l'imaginé depuis la
france déjà c'est pas la première fois
que ça arrive
14 les précédentes élections en 2014 et
même en 2009 puisque abdullah abdullah
qui n'a pas la fonction de premier
ministre mais du chef de l'exécutif
puisque la constitution afghane ne
prévoit pas ce poste avait déjà contesté
les élections donc énorme est à sa 3ème
contestation il a avalé la pilule c'est
j'ose dire
lors des deux précédentes de précédentes
élections présidentielles et donc là il
est dans une logique où il ne veut
absolument pas cédé le moindre mètre par
rapport à son adversaire qui qu'il a
péniblement et les manières assez
fragile et exercer le pouvoir
comment est ce possible tout simplement
parce que le processus électoral a été
très compliqué avec un certain nombre de
violences qui ont émaillé ce processus
qui ont empêché d'avoir un certain
nombre de résultats deuxièmement il ya
eu des contestations elles portent sur
l'ensemble des votes avec là aussi
faut-il le rappeler un pourcentage très
faible moins de 10% des neuf millions
d'électeurs se sont déclarés faso sont
présentés au scrutin pour les raisons de
sécurité que j'évoquais précédemment
et donc cette contestation du reste a
toujours lieu puisque le premier
ministre le chef des députés
abdou labo de la part du principe que
tous les votes n'ont pas été recomptées
et la marge de manoeuvre telle qu'elle a
été annoncée
assez rapidement par le président
élus et donc investi aujourd'hui ashraf
ghani ne porte que sur douze mille voix
alors cette crise constitutionnelle
comment on en sort est ce qu elle peut
durer longtemps
il avait fallu trois mois en 2014 et
l'implication personnelle de john kerry
à l'époque secrétaire d'état américain
qui avait fait littéralement la navette
entre les deux camps le camp d'abdullah
abdullah et le camp d'achraf années pour
obtenir effectivement ce set
comment dire c'est ce mariage un petit
peu un petit peu alambiqué entre les
deux hommes qui ne peut plus avoir lieu
puisque les négociations des jours
précédents ils se sont d'ailleurs
déroulée la nuit dernière n'ont pas
abouti on sait avec un certain nombre de
précautions que le président shafran y
est prêt à faire un gouvernement d'union
nationale avec une large part au camp
adverse donc de son adversaire à de la
boule à 30 à 40% du gouvernement mais
avec une détermination et donc une
certitude de ne pas avoir dit la boule à
être de nouveau dans la même
configuration qu'en 2014 aux commandes
en sortons tout simplement avec la
pression américaine et je crois
d'ailleurs qu'elle est forte
actuellement le secrétaire d'état marie
pons p ô a appelé personnellement achraf
rani en lui demandant de choses
d'accélérer le processus d'investiture
alors qu'il avait reculé les jours
précédents tout simplement parce qu'il
ya une urgence à ce que l'accord qui a
été signé il ya une semaine et dont la
réalisation devrait devait avoir lieu
demain avec la deuxième étape la mise en
place d'un dialogue intra afghans c'est
à dire entre le gouvernement afghan qui
en étaient exclues et la délégation
talibane qui est actuellement à kaboul
et malheureusement ce dialogue va être
tout à fait perturbé d'ailleurs les
talibans ont dit qu'ils étaient prêts à
le repousser
car ils ne veulent surtout pas avoir à
négocier avec un camp sachant que 39 12
% c'est le score de la droite globe ne
reconnaît pas le résultat de ces
négociations ou ne reconnaîtra pas le
résultat de ces négociations
alors cette grande confusion
enseignements qu'on puisse dire sur
cette présidentielle alors que l'armée
américaine a commencé à se retirer
d'afghanistan après son accord de paix
signé avec
les talibans ça fait beaucoup ça fait un
départ des américains alors que
finalement l'afghanistan n'est pas du
tout stable cet accord avec les talibans
se demande son efficacité à les
américains avaient déjà commencé à se
replier bien avant l'accord
d'ailleurs l'accord a été repoussée de
plusieurs mois il ya six mois de cela
en septembre le négociateur zalman
relizane était à deux doigts d'ailleurs
à quelques jours voire quelques heures
de cette nature de cet accord il avait
fallu une attaque revendiquée par les
talibans qui avait coûté la vie à un
soldat américain est du reste un soldat
roumain également pour le remettre en
cause donc les américains n'ont pas
attendu cet accord pour essayer
d'aborder dans le sens de la promesse
présidentielle que le président donald
trump avait faite à l'occasion de son
élection de sa précédente élection et
qu'il a reformulée à l'occasion du
prochain scrutin en novembre 2020
les américains partent mais partent avec
un calendrier qui est très très étalée
on parle de 14 mois
ils partent de manière séquencée où les
1600 sur les quatorze mille qui sont
actuellement présents au sein d'une
opération otanienne la vraie question
c'est que vont faire les partenaires
donc les autres nations les 28 autres
nations qui appartiennent à l'opération
otanienne qui a donc succédé à
l'opération qui avait évidemment pour
but de chasser des talibans alors que
l'objectif même et le président
américain a été assez limpide pour une
fois c'est de réintroduire les talibans
dans le jeu politique il a même été
assez cynique en disant qu'il est
possible que vu l'état de déconfiture si
on autorise l expression des deux camps
que les talibans finalement ne soit la
solution la plus stable dans le contexte
où nous sommes ce soir
est ce que finalement cette stratégie
s'est avérée payante négocier avec les
talibans ça dépend de quel point de vue
on parle du point de vue afghans n'ont
d'ailleurs les afghans ne se
reconnaissent pas dans ce processus
il avale quand même beaucoup de couleurs
près de dix huit années 19ème en année
qui ont coûté la vie à cent mille
afghans avec un coup absolument
considérable on parle de 4000 milliards
de dollars qui ont été dépensés pour le
conflit
avec évidemment des victimes autant
civils que militaires
les américains imposent ou mettre une
pression assez considérable sur le
président un des deux présidents
autoproclamés d'un proclamé pardon
investi achraf rani qui dans son
discours a laissé entendre que ce qui ne
voulait pas accepter c'est à dire la
libération des cinq mille prisonniers
talibans pourrait éventuellement faire
le jeu d'un compromis
donc l'état les afghans n'ont pas eu
leur mot à dire à la fois dans les
termes de cet accord de paix qui précise
qu' précisément s'appuie sur quatre
points à cesser le feu
un dialogue intra afghan la libération
d'un certain nombre de prisonniers
talibans contre la libération de 1000
forces de sécurité afghanes qui sont
entre les mains des talibans et puis la
promesse mais là aussi avec beaucoup de
guillemets que le mouvement taliban ne
soit plus en lien avec les organismes
terroriste al-qaïda nommément mais l'on
sait que dans tout accord de paix il y a
des absents il a quelques jours vendredi
précisément 32 personnes sont mortes à
l'issue d'une heure d'un attentat qui
n'a pas été revendiqué par les pairs des
banques mais par l'état islamique en
afghanistan qu'il ne se reconnaît dans
absolument aucun des termes de cet
accord tend justement cet attentat
revendiqué aujourd'hui un par lui lors
des cérémonies d'investiture
concurrentes
ça dit quoi finalement qu' on est
totalement impuissant à faire la paix
dans ce pays
cela dit que l'accord de paix n'en est
pas un que l'accord de paix est avant
tout un accord entre les américains et
les talibans précisément entre les
américains et l'émirat islamique
d'afghanistan
d'ailleurs dans l'accord en question il
est précisé que les américains ne le
reconnaissent pas cette organisation
mais la manière dont les talibans s'en
revendiquent montre à quel point les
américains ont d'une certaine façon un
peu de capituler de ce point de vue ça
dit surtout que le gouvernement d'achat
frannie est sous la coupe américaine
avec 80 % du budget des de l'état qui
dépend de l'aide extérieure
il peut difficilement en être autrement
ça dit également qu'il y à une césure
qui est en train de se créer entre les
jeux politiciens à kaboul qui ressemble
beaucoup à la période qui avait précédé
l'arrivée des talibans 96 la guerre
civile
entre 1992 et 1996 on est dans une
configuration où à quelques centaines de
mètres deux membres qui jusqu'à présent
avaient exercé un magistère régalien
pour l'exercice donc de la souveraineté
afghane se font la guerre politiquement
avec peut-être un peu plus de
préoccupations à voir dans les jours qui
viennent avec d'ores et déjà adoula
d'oulad qui a envoyé son vice-président
dans le palais présidentiel pour exercer
sa vice-présidence et un certain nombre
de districts un certain nombre de
gouverneurs qu'ils sont placés par les
uns et les autres avec cette grande
interrogation que ferait l'armée s'ils
recevaient l'ordre de déloger un camp ou
l'autre
merci beaucoup emmanuel dupuis pour
votre analyse complète merci à vous les
retours en france où les droits des
femmes célébrée hier à travers le monde
également en france donc violence
machiste harcèlement de rue féminicide
mambé égalité dans les entreprises
autant d'injustice qu'il faut continuer
à combattre c'était le message des
manifestations hier à paris le cortège
est parti place d'italie pour rallier la
place de la république une marche qui
s'est terminée dans la tension
la police a fait usage de gaz
lacrymogènes
aujourd'hui c'est la journée
internationale de lutte pour le droit
des femmes donc oui c'est important
d'être là c'est important d'être
mobilisés c'est important d'être sur
paris pour ramener à ramener un maximum
de personnes et montrer qu'on est les
plus fortes les plus forts ce que je
pense que c'est un combat de tous et les
femmes c'est les hommes c'est tout le
monde est un moment faut se mobiliser
tous ensemble
le 8 mars est une journée symbolique
parce que c'est là où on dit c'est la
journée internationale des droits des
femmes et la lutte allait tous les jours
c'est tous les jours il faut se battre
c'est tous les jours il faut défendre
nos droits acquis et acquérir de
nouveaux droits on s'aperçoit que le
patriarcat est encore très présent et
donc voilà on vient ici pour exprimer
notre colère
important aussi que les gouvernements en
place voit que ça va au delà du pays et
que toutes les femmes du monde entier
lutte pour on ne lutte pas que pour nous
on nous on lutte pour les femmes
migrantes on lutte pour les invisibles
est femme de ménage notamment leur lutte
à l'hôtel ibis donc voilà on lutte pour
toutes ces femmes et pour donner cette
visibilité le 8 mars un combat toute
l'année c'est pas de la journée de la
femme c'est la journée des droits des
femmes et de défense de droits des
femmes et
le nombre de féministes qui augmente
chaque année en france
le fait que la loi qu'on la réforme
contre les retraites serait une
catastrophe pour les femmes
voilà pourquoi nous on est venu
aujourd'hui sur paris pour faire la
manif les actions et montrer que c'est
tout et tout ensemble qu'on arrivera à
lutter à gagner des nouveaux droits que
ce soit pour les femmes et pour tout le
monde et est la veille de cette journée
des droits des femmes qui avait lieu
hier on vous le rappelle une
manifestation féministe nocturne s'était
organisé à paris une mobilisation
marquée par l'évacuation forcée et l'
usage de gaz lacrymogènes les forces de
l'ordre certains parlent de violences
policières le préfet de police de paris
didier lallement est pointé du doigt
didier lallement qui est également au
coeur des révélations de nos confrères
de mediapart site s'est procuré des
notes de la gendarmerie elle ferait état
de l'illégalité des ordres donnés par le
préfet mais disque est fier avec lucas
tu as
le préfet l'allemand un peu plus dans la
tourmente depuis ce samedi et les
incidents qui ont éclaté à paris à la
veille de la journée internationale du
droit des femmes l'image qui fait
scandale
les forces de l'ordre qui bouscule
violemment des manifestantes
un épisode qui ravive les accusations
récurrentes à l'encontre de didier
lallement déjà vivement critiqué depuis
plusieurs mois l'opposition s'est
empressée de réagir sur la toile
l'allemand est un violent indigne de la
république cela fait des mois que nous
demandons que dégagent les bornes year
castetner et sont serviles préfet
l'allemand suffit ils doivent partir
l'allemand des chaînes le machisme
grossier des policiers contre la marche
des femmes
le syndicat miliciens synergie police va
plus loin le camp du préfet l'allemand
commence à puylaurens mais qui contrôle
encore l'extrême droite policière macron
et castaner en ont peur choquée par les
violences
inadmissible et incompréhensible la nuit
dernière place de la république
soutien aux manifestantes et
manifestants le préfet de police didier
lallement mis en cause la préfecture de
police répond dans un communiqué de
presse publié ce dimanche didier
lallement préfet de police déplore que
la fin de cette manifestation pourtant
régulièrement déclarés est été entachée
d'incidents qui sont manifestement le
fait d'individus ayant pour seul but de
provoquer les forces de l'ordre et de
perturber le bon déroulé de l'événement
à 63 ans l'irréductible fans de la
légion étrangère divise également en
interne des membres du gouvernement
d'edouard philippe demande des comptes
illustration avec la secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes
toutes les femmes doivent pouvoir
manifester pacifiquement pour faire
respecter leurs droits
le ministre christophe castaner a
demandé un rapport à la préfecture de
police sur ce qui s'est passé en marge
de la marche féministe polémique à
laquelle s'ajoutent des révélations de
mediapart
le journal se serait procuré des notes
de la gendarmerie nationale et de crs
qui pointe du doigt des emplois
disproportionné de la force notamment
lors des manifestations
la gendarmerie nationale qui jugeraient
contraire à la législation les pratiques
du préfet notamment celle de
l'engagement pratique qui consiste à
masser les manifestants d'après
mediapart les crs se plaindre également
de l' usage abusif de tirs de gaz
lacrymogène ordonnée par la préfecture
de police
une remise en cause de la gestion
sécuritaire qui intervient à quelques
jours de l'appel national à manifester
du 14 mars
une mobilisation particulièrement
redouté par l'exécutif puisqu'elle aura
lieu un an après les violents heurts des
champs elysées lors de l'acte 18d gilet
jaune assez avec ton dans quelques
instants nous parlerons des ventes
d'armes la france qui se hisse de la
cinquième à la troisième place des plus
gros explique l'exportateur mondiaux
et puis nous reviendrons sur le procès
des époux fillon qui entame sa dernière
ligne droite reste eric
[Musique]
et
l'arrivée de l'assemblée est ce qu'on
peut parler de révolution
techniquement oui on peut parler de
révolution est ce qu'on pourrait pas
réservé sa à des applications bien
précise plutôt que vouloir absolument le
mettre à disposition de tout le monde il
faut avoir en tête pour que pour chaque
génération il faut qu'elle soit
accompagnée d'un killer application
ça veut dire développer une application
qui fait le bouc est ce que on a bien
mesuré toute la dépense énergétique de
nouveaux terminaux de nouvelle
implantation de relais le futur de la
cinq cdc des systèmes de communication à
très haut débit ciment vont enfin
télécharger un film plus vite
qu'est ce que ça va vous apporter les
craintes c'est parce qu'il ya un manque
d'information est probablement un manque
de collaboration est ce que aujourd'hui
le monde entier a besoin de la ceinture
en inde il n'existe pas de statistiques
officielles sur les enfants perdus ou
séparés de leurs parents
selon certaines informations un enfant
disparaît toutes les huit minutes dans
le pays
cet enfant est avec vous ou allez vous
[Musique]
elle est avec toi et lui
il est aussi avec toi il vous accompagne
je ne sais pas je connais pas son nom
selon la commission nationale des droits
de l'homme 44 mille mineurs
disparaissent chaque année
la police déclare qu ils sont 88 mille
enfants le fonds des nations-unies pour
l'enfance qualifie cette situation de
génocide et donne le chiffre de 12
millions d'enfants
que veut-il dire en japonais et qui
comme on veut quand il veut dire qu'il
ne sort pas de chez soi tout simplement
le propre du phénomène hikikomori c'est
que on trouve des jeunes au japon qui
refuse de sortir de chez eux alors
qu'eux ils n'ont pas de pathologie
identifiée dans la nomenclature
psychiatriques aujourd'hui les quais
komori ne sont pas des fadas de jeux
vidéo c'est pas des gens qui passent
tout leur temps dans leur chambre
scotché à l'ordinateur à jouer aux jeux
vidéo et c'est un documentaire qui
permet de comprendre en quoi ce
phénomène est vraiment spécifique de la
culture japonaise au japon la pression
scolaire est extrêmement forte
mais les parents s'endettent souvent à
vie pour que leurs enfants fassent des
études et puis vous savez au moment de
la crise d'adolescence un bel quelque
chose qui est remis en question
c'est une super méga crise d'adolescence
considérablement majorait par la
situation économique culturel social
familial qui lie au japon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
21h heure française merci de nous
rejoindre en direct sur rt france voici
les titres de l'actualité de ce lundi
la france se hisse à la troisième place
du classement des pays d'exporter
exportateur d'armes l'hexagone
représente 7,9 pour cent du marché
mondial un record depuis 1990 aux deux
premières places les états unis et la
russie
le procès des époux fillon ont jugé pour
des soupçons d'emploi fictif entre dans
sa dernière ligne droite
ce lundi c'est l'omission de
déclarations à la haute autorité de
transparence de la vie publique d'une
partie de son patrimoine ou de ses
intérêts qui est examinée l'ex premier
ministre qui plaide l'erreur honnête la
menace d'une pandémie est devenu très
réelles selon l' oms en france le bilan
s'aggrave avec vingt cinq morts le
ministre de la culture franck riester a
été testé positif on a appris ce soir
les rassemblements de plus de 1000
personnes sont désormais interdits quant
à l'italie 15 millions de personnes ont
été placées en quarantaine hier alors
quelles mesures faut-il prendre pour
endiguer le coronavirus bottines suivent
l'exemple italien
ce sera l'objet de notre face à face à
21h30
[Musique]
le sipri l'institut international de
recherche pour la paix vient de dévoiler
son tout dernier rapport concernant les
ventes d'armes dans le monde
sans surprise les etats-unis sont les
plus gros vendeurs de matériel
d'armement sur la planète loin devant la
russie et la france
hexagone qui connaît néanmoins une
dynamique impressionnante en la matière
thomas bonnet pour les explications
quand les tensions géopolitiques sont de
plus en plus fortes et nombreuses il y
en a qui se frotte les mains ce sont les
fabricants et les vendeurs d'armes sur
la période analysée par le sipri
c'est-à-dire de 2015 à 2019 les affaires
sont plutôt bonnes le commerce mondial
des armes a connu une croissance de 5 et
demi pour cent par rapport à la période
précédente de 2010 à 2014
les plus gros exportateurs d'armes dans
le monde sans trop de surprise ce sont
les américains avec désormais 36 % de
part de marché la russie est deuxième
avec 21 % et la france complète ce
podium avec pas loin de 8% au-delà de ce
classement ce qui est intéressant c'est
de relever les dynamiques en cours
ainsi les états unis ont gagné des parts
de marché à linverse de la russie dont
les ventes ont reculé ces dernières
années mais la hausse la plus notable
concerne la france
ces cinq dernières années l'hexagone a
enregistré une augmentation de ses
ventes d'armes à hauteur de 72%
avec 7 9 % des parts du marché mondial
la france passe donc de la 5e à la 3e
place de ce classement est atteint un
record d'exportation d'armements datant
de 1990
cette augmentation fait suite aux
efforts continus du gouvernement
français pour promouvoir les
exportations d'armes
l'industrie française a bénéficié des
commandes de l'egypte du qatar et de
l'inde
maintenant qu'on sait qui vend les armes
penchons nous sur les acheteurs de ces
blindés frégates et autres sous marins
plus d'un tiers des armes importées le
sont par des pays du moyen-orient
le plus gros importateur est sans
conteste l'arabie saoudite avec 12% du
total des importations d'armes sur la
planète
là encore ce qui est notable c'est la
dynamique de cette proportion ryad a
acheté 130 % d'armes de plus que sur la
période
précédente dans son rapport le sipri est
un institut de recherche sur la paire
regrette ces flux d'armes vers des pays
en conflit
vendre des armes à l'arabie saoudite ou
aux émirats arabes unis alors même que
ces deux pays mènent une guerre au yémen
cela avait provoqué des remous
importants dans l'opinion notamment en
europe
l'allemagne a ainsi mis en place un
embargo sur ses exportations vers ryad
alors que dans le même temps emmanuel
macron dit assumer la vente d'armes
françaises à l'arabie saoudite
la bonne santé du secteur de l'armement
c'est un succès parfois difficile à
défendre ce qui est bon pour l'économie
ne l'est pas forcément dans la
perception de l'opinion publique
un dilemme qui risquent de se présenter
à nouveau dans les prochaines années
le sipri estime que les exportations
d'armes françaises ne devraient pas
baisser significativement durant les
cinq prochaines années et pour en parler
nous sommes avec atonie fortin chargée
d'études à l'observatoire des armements
bonsoir tony force un merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france on a
entendu cette belle progression de la
france en matière de ventes d'armes
première question est ce qu'on doit s'en
réjouir
ce coût doit s'en réjouir tout dépend de
quel bord aux passions pèse du point de
vue de l'état
effectivement ou des industries de
l'armement tout à fait le problème c'est
qu'en effectivement regarde à quoi et
dans quel est le sens de ces ventes
d'armes à quoi ça certes s'aperçoit
quand même que ces dernières années ses
exportations d'armes ont servi à
préparer la guerre au yémen avait sorti
une étude il ya quelques années qui
montrait très bien comment en fait les
contrats qu'ils correspondent
effectivement à ces chiffres mirobolants
d'explosion indépendament correspond
effectivement à l'équipement des forces
saoudiennes qui pour l'alimenter dans sa
guerre au yémen
on avait enfin fameux contrat donne à ce
qui était initialement destiné au liban
et dans les armes étaient payés par
l'arabie saoudite armes qui ont été
récupérées ensuite par l'arabie saoudite
mais on a tout lieu de penser que ce
contrat n'était qu'un cas par avant donc
on voit bien comment à travers ses
ventes d'armes on est un petit peu
responsable aussi co responsable avec
d'autres pays du drame humanitaire qui
se joue actuellement au yémen et il n'y
a pas que le yémen y aussi les gîtes un
aussi on a fourni énormément de
technologies de surveillance de la
population et de répression au moment où
le maréchal est si si on avait besoin
donc donc on voit bien comment l'impact
délétère est effectivement de ses
exportations d'armes et le fait aussi un
que c'est insuffisamment questionné dans
le débat public
le débat public justement le
gouvernement ne communique pas beaucoup
sur ses faits d'armes justement c'est le
cas de le dire sur ce succès quand on a
parlé effectivement de la guerre ou au
yémen on sentait un certain embarras
de la ministre des armées qui a affirmé
en tout cas que ça n'avait jamais servi
à tuer des civils
il ya vraiment effectivement une volonté
peut-être de cacher les choses du
gouvernement vous n'avez pas cette
impression
cachez ces suprême c'est le un problème
structurel aujourd'hui qui détient le
pouvoir dans le fait de décider où les
armes par dans quel pays
et bien c'est le gouvernement c'est la
siem jeu ça dépend des services du
premier ministre et le problème c'est
que le parlement n'est pas dans la
boucle
il n'est pas au courant des contrats
d'armement qui sont en négociation et un
rapport au parlement qui paraît chaque
année mais qui est totalement complet
incomplet il n'ya pas les détails des
armements livrer les types de quantité
les les mentions précise des armes qui
font l'objet
effectivement des négociations donc donc
on voit bien comment aujourd'hui ben on
on est dans une forme de deux tabous
d'absence de débat au parlement et le
gouvernement à la fois en charge de
l'exportation d'armes mais aussi de leur
contrôle et il s'agit aujourd'hui
d'arriver à déverrouiller ça à faire en
sorte qu'il ya un tiers les
parlementaires qui s'insère dans ce
dispositif est que le citoyen puisse est
au courant et puissent aussi est informé
de cette politique internationale de la
france que ce soit enfin dans le débat
public
il serait temps alors 72% à vous avez
expliqué les raisons de cette
progression mais pourquoi la france
finalement pourquoi ces pays ont fait le
choix de la france ça aurait pu être
d'autres pays comme les etats unis ou la
russie
par exemple le sipri épingle épingle la
france dans ce communiqué parce que il
est l organisme a constaté une
augmentation faramineuse de ses
exportations d'armes de l'ordre de 72 %
sur la période 2015 2019 par rapport à
la période 2010 2014
ce qu'on peut dire par là c'est
qu'est-ce que ça questionne ou fond
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça dit
qu'est ce que veut dire ces chiffres
parce que c'est très abstrait au final
bon comme on l'a vu il ya des
conséquences sur les populations civiles
mais si la france vend des armes c'est
pas pour des raisons économiques puisque
le total des exportations d'armes dans
dans le total des exportations
françaises est infiniment faible c'est
un peu plus d'un pour cent
donc si on exporte des armes c'est avant
tout pour équiper nos propres forces
armées là encore il faut pas l'oublier
parce que le marché national est trop
étroit et donc pour alimenter les
chaînes de production des usines
d'armement où on est obligé de
d'exporter à à l'étranger mais c'est
aussi parce qu'on souhaite développer
des relations avec un certain nombre de
régimes c'est pour des intérêts qui sont
on l'a vu on l'a noté dans un rapport
que l'on a sorti l'année dernière
cosigné avec des amis de la terre et ce
mot veut que la france intervenait oui
et même était en guerre au yémen
précisément pour des intérêts
énergétiques gazier un aussi pour être
présents dans la région en l'océan
indien alors ça ce type de politique de
puissance n est pas spécifique à la
france c'est les etats-unis la russie
font exactement la même chose
simplement nous on est le citoyen
français est ce qu'on demande c'est
qu'elle puisse être mise en débat qu'on
puisse aujourd'hui avoir un débat sur
cette implication de la france au yémen
en egypte et conçoit pas tout le temps
en train de décès de courir derrière les
infos de faire de recherche qui prennent
énormément de temps mais que les
parlementaires se saisissent eux mêmes
de ces questions comme c'est le cas
d'ailleurs au royaume uni en allemagne
où il bénéficie d'une commission dédiée
qui leur permet justement de 2,2
d'enquêter sur ces transferts
d'armements d'en discuter de rédiger un
contre rapport avec des données aussi
qui paraissent très régulièrement sur
les transferts d'armes
aujourd'hui on reste sur un modèle qui
est le modèle un petit peu gaulliste en
france avec une concentration du pouvoir
autour de la plaie de la figure du
président de la république une très très
grande opacité sur la politique est
malgré tout des opérations militaires
des exportations d'armes qui seraient
lisa à l'insu des citoyens sont qu'on en
soit informée pour des butins bon qui
nous concerne puisque les questions de
dépendance énergétique c'est quelque
chose aujourd'hui qu'on peut mettre dans
le débat public
il ne s'agit pas de caricaturer mais il
faut que ce débat il faut que ce débat
ait lieu
et aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas alors
vous paraît effectivement de la russie
et des états unis un états unis première
position aussi deuxième moscou il
n'empêche qu'ils accusent une baisse de
18% de ses ventes en 2015 2019
pour quelle raison justement alors que
la france progresse autant la russie
elle recul comment l'expliquer le sipri
indique ce indique effectivement que la
russie est la russie aujourd'hui père
perd un petit peu sa place en inde
après si on revient aujourd'hui sur
l'historique des frais des relations
franco russes
c'est plutôt en voie de réchauffement on
sait que ça a été le cas par le passé il
ya eu toujours des relations
voilà avec avec la russie et du et du
partage une coopération en matière
d'armement notamment 2009 qui a été qui
s'est beaucoup développée sous nicolas
sarkozy
ça a été remise en cause par par la
suite du fait de l'intervention de la
france en libye et aussi des opérations
russes en syrie mais on voit bien
aujourd'hui avec mêmes mal macron que
bon on revient d'une certaine façon à
cette coopération qui a pu exister entre
les français et les russes avec
peut-être de futurs contrats d'armements
dans le futur en haut on n'est pas là
mais on concède quand même un
réchauffement
merci beaucoup anthony fortin chargée
d'études à l'observatoire des armements
d'avoir été en direct avec nous avoir
apporté votre analyse merci à vous merci
l'actualité en france est également
aujourd'hui la reprise du procès de
françois fillon et de son épouse ils
sont poursuivis pour détournement de
fonds public et encourt jusqu'à dix ans
de prison et une lourde amende les
précisions sur place de notre reporter
katia pique nique
c'est la dernière ligne droite du procès
fillon aujourd'hui à la 32ème chambre se
sont déroulées les interrogatoires de
personnalité des prévenus ainsi que la
plaidoirie de maître yves claisse
l'avocat de l'assemblée nationale alors
il s'est étonné que la jurisprudence
soit invoquée par la défense de françois
fillon
en effet cette dernière estime que si
les époux fillon et marc joulaud été
condamné et bien l'assemblée nationale
ne devrait pas recevoir de compensation
car elle aurait commis des fautes
alors quelle faute 1 s'est étonné
l'avocat
car il y aurait-il eu par exemple un
manque de contrôle et bien le contrôle
c'était plutôt aux députés de l'assuré à
savoir françois fillon et marc joulaud
et puis juste un exemple le déontologue
la défense lui reprocherait de ne pas
avoir contrôlé les agissements de
pénélope fillon or à l'époque le
déontologue n'était pas encore en poste
et puis il ya le volet de la réparation
je vous propose d'écouter m yves classe
à ce sujet je réclame exclusivement un
préjudice financier encore une fois kiné
qui est conditionnée par la condamnation
et qui est subsidiaire là
la nation mais ce que je réclame en
termes chiffrés
c'est un million 80000 euros qui
correspondent exclusivement à des
rémunérations ainsi que des charges
sociales qui pendant donc onze ans de
contrat s'agissant l'assemblée nationale
devrait être considéré comme ayant été
indûment versés si encore une fois le
tribunal rentrer en voie de condamnation
au fil des audiences pénélope fillon a
eu les plus grandes peines du monde à
justifier son activité les fameux
conseil qu'elle aurait prodigué ou
encore l'aide qu'elle aurait apporté et
puis de toute manière les archives
supposées auraient été détruites selon
le couple fillon en tout cas il existe
bien des preuves d'activités de pénélope
fillon puisqu'elle a bien assisté à des
rassemblements à des inaugurations
mais pour les procureurs il ne s'agit
que d'un rôle social
en revanche la défense estime que toutes
les preuves de son activité
parlementaire ont été fournies au cours
de ce procès d'ailleurs des témoins ont
apporté en témoigner en faveur de
pénélope fillon je vous propose de
l'écouter qui a été utile lors de cette
audience si vous avez eu de très
nombreux témoins trois témoins de sa
venue en personne et des raies nombreux
témoignages camp et élus qui ont
détaillé le travail de pénélope fillon
aux côtés de son époux et aux côtés de
marc joulaud et c'était moins là sauf à
imaginer la plus grande entreprise
jamais réalisé c'est quand même la mafia
sicilienne n'a jamais réussi à faire ça
de subornation de 14 personnes de trois
préfets de un sous-préfet de gens qui ne
se connaissent pas sauf à rentrer dans
cette théorie complètement folle absurde
et ce totalement stupide de dire que 14
personnes sont capables de mentir devant
les enquêteurs
le fait est qu à la fin de cette
audience toutes ces personnes ont
témoigné chacune à leur manière du
travail qu'elle réalise le 10 mars
reprise des audiences à 13h30 avec les
plaidoiries de la défense qui devrait
durer un long moment selon leur avocat
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec didier gallot ancien juge
d'instruction bonsoir vie
gallo merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france cros et fillon qui
rentre donc dans sa dernière ligne
droite
en tant qu'ancien juge d'instruction
quel est votre regard sur les audiences
et sur le procès en cours a chuté sur le
procès lui même je ne le suis pas je en
revanche j'ai longuement étudié le le
coup monté et donc éviter fillon grâce
je dirais à l'intervention du parquet
national financier mieux invention d'une
rapidité absolument étonnante
surprenante terrifiante d'ailleurs
puisque vous savez que le matin du 25 g
veuillez vous avez le l'article canard
enchaîné et le soir même le soir même
une enquête est ouverte par madame où
l'ex procureur du parquet national
financier parquet national financiers
donc je me permets de vous rappeler
qu'il s'agit une structure verticale qui
supprime toute intervention des autres
procureurs de france dans les affaires
politico financières
autant dire un outil terrible pour
traquer laser certes politique et
j'estime que françois fillon dans cette
affaire a été victime d'un véritable
coup monté à partir d'une d'une
information du canard enchaîné que
réguler normalement passer car vous
savez bien que tous les parlementaires
pratiquement employés des proches tous
il ya ceux qui étaient mariés donc ça se
voyait
mais il ya ceux qui avait des maîtresses
des amants qui embauchait ceux ou celles
de leurs collègues et tous ceux ci
rentrait dans une enveloppe globale mais
ils viennent ou pardonnez moi vous êtes
je ne sais pas moi qui vais vous
apprendre la loi bien évidemment mais
sauf erreur de ma part ce n'est pas
forcément illégale d'embaucher son
épouse sa maîtresse ont maintenant peu
importe d'ailleurs mais ce qui est
illégal c'est le côté emploi fictif
c'est l'embauché alors qu'il ne fait
rien et sur ce point on aura la réponse
est évidemment prochainement mais
françois fillon est mis en difficulté
aujourd'hui ça son épouse pénélope a
bien de peine à répondre aux questions
justement du procureur et au juge qui
sont des fonctionnaires de contrôler ce
qui est laid
évitez du parlementaire là
l'intervention de l'attaché
parlementaire n'étant pas prévus si vous
n'hésitez pas défini il n'y a pas de
profil de poste à l'assemblée nationale
est ce que l'élu la nation après tout
moi j'ai été élu j'ai double casquette
j'ai été juge d'instruction et j'ai été
maire des sables d'olonne il ya quand
même une légitimité qui revient qui est
celle de l'élue qui a reçu l'onction du
suffrage universel
et puis elle fonctionnaires qui
intervient dans le domaine de ce qui
revient au pouvoir législatif est dans
la sphère fillon j'estime que la
séparation des pouvoirs n'a pas été
respecté et ce n'est pas un juge
quelque soit d'aller contrôler
l'activité de l'attaché parlementaire
d'un député
moi je suis désolé j'appartiens à une
génération commence la terre de décence
commença ses loyers dans le temps
j'avais démissionné pour présenter aux
sables aux hommes j'étais encore en
activité en 2014 mais l'été
traditionnels que dans les affaires
impliquant des gens susceptibles d'être
élus au personnel politique on arrêtait
les opérations de denquête six mois
avant l'élection pour ne pas fausser ou
risquer de fausser le résultat du
suffrage universel à moi l'histoire
d'aller contrôler leurs activités de
même fillon est ce qu'elle faisait ce si
elle questionné cela j'estime que la
justice est hors sujet et nous risquons
fort
ils nourrissent confort d'avoir des
surprises parce que le problème de la
séparation des pouvoirs a été clairement
soulevée par la défense alors après on
va retrouver des témoins un moi
j'observe simplement que pour une
affaire de cornecul emploi du nez blues
d'enfance
encore une fois tout se faisait on a
mobilisé des services de police
judiciaire
selon le service pendant des mois ils
n'ont fait que ça au même moment où
parallélisme des formes
monsieur richard ferrand l'actuel
président de l'assemblée nationale et
qui est l'objet aussi d'une enquête se
voyait lui alors bel se voyait
bénéficier d'une course de lenteur
le lièvre c'est fillon la tortue ces
félons du même parti d'un studio qui est
une création je vous rappelle de
l'époque de monsieur hollande
monsieur hollande qui avait dû faire
face à cette affaire terrible pour la
classe politique que représentait le
dossier cahuzac
on a créé ce parti national financier
qui est une machine à blanchir les très
grosses infractions financières et
empoisonner la concurrence didier quel
nom pardonnez moi de vous couper mais je
voudrais poser quand même une ou deux
questions pour vous voilà parquet
national
c'est très bien mais à distance c'est
plus compliqué de poser des questions
donc parquet national financier politisé
on l'aura compris un mono dit qu'on
clair la séparation des pouvoirs n'a pas
été respecté l'indépendance de la
justice non plus par définition mais
finalement est-ce qu'elle est au service
de la droite de la gauche où aller
contre tous au moment au gré du temps
c'est ce que vous nous dites aujourd'hui
ici donc le livre que vient de sortir
des grands as assez vieux judiciaire de
fillon à touquet vous savez un procureur
chabbi ça obéit aux ordres
encore plus qu'un militaire il est
devenu véritable culture de soumission
il ya deux branches magistrature vous
avez les juges du siège
je n'ai jamais eu au parquet au grand
jamais et puis il ya le parquet qui
représente le pouvoir exécutif fort avec
le parquet national financiers
le pouvoir est parvenu à reprendre la
main
1 quand vous avez 173 procureur 173 pour
l'instruction il y a des trous dans le
filet il ya ce que j'appelle la lea
judiciaire c'est à dire que vous risquez
un accident judiciaire lorsque vous avez
un procureur unique traitant toutes les
affaires politico financières qui est à
paris très forcément proches du pouvoir
on me raconte pas d'histoires la
l'indépendance du parquet elle existe
dans leur imagination qui est fertile
dans ce domaine aucune indépendance les
ordres l'exécution et après il suffit
d'ouvrir une information de bien choisir
le juge ce cas quelqu'un en espèces
didier galy il est évident qu'il ya
beaucoup d'observateurs vous n'êtes pas
le seul évidemment avoir relevé ça
pendant cette campagne présidentielle
certainement avec beaucoup
d'opportunités voilà cette information
est parue dans la presse il n'empêche
selon vous vous êtes un homme de droite
vous en cachez pas vous est présentée
aux sables d'olonne
l'atv-2 l'exécutent de françois fillon
ne l'a pas enfoncé si j'ose dire il
aurait peut-être pu mieux se défendre
c'est peut-être 100 a perdu au final
j'estime qu'il est très mal défendu il
ay l'a fait il a adopté une attitude à
l'époque de connivence espérant comme
lui n'a jamais vu à mon avis je ne
connais pas prendre soin puis je l' ai
vu une fois croisé une fois dandy pop
ali nestor des sables des congrès des
sables d'olonne mais je pense qu'il a
cru
il n'a pas un passé de haut
fonctionnaire une sais pas comment ça
fonctionne de laterrière en réalité et
jay à mentalité des gens est il mort et
leur potentiel de nuisance
donc il va il a cru qu'il avait accroché
le non pas le non lieu mais le
classement sans suite mais en réalité
ils ont fait signer la blessure pendant
des mois il n'y a pas eu de débat le
françois fillon n'a pas pu exprimer
exposer son programme on n'a parlé que
l'emploi de son épouse
merci en tout cas à didier ganneau
ancien juge d'instruction également une
politique et écrivain
merci à vous ben bongo s'était déjà
présenté aux sables d'olonne lauder
rollin vous l'aviez vous êtes
indépendant j'étais indépendant gt by
vers droite sans étiquette aurélie tu
vois là précisément merci en tout cas
didier
gallo d'avoir été avec nous donc
quelques instants rester avec nous ce
sera notre face à face sur les effets du
coronavirus alors que la menace d'une
pandémie est devenu très réelles selon
l' oms quelles mesures faut-il prendre
pour endiguer cette crise faut-il suivre
l'exemple italien nos invités en
débattrons
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même ici
on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas d'accord
ici qu'on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
en inde il n'existe pas de statistiques
officielles sur les enfants perdus ou
séparés de leurs parents
selon certaines informations un enfant
disparaît toutes les huit minutes dans
le pays
cet enfant est avec vous ou allez vous
[Musique]
elle est avec toi les lui
il est aussi avec toi il vous accompagne
je ne sais pas je connais pas son nom
selon la commission nationale des droits
de l'homme 44 mille mineurs
disparaissent chaque année
la police déclare qu ils sont 88 mille
enfants le fonds des nations unies pour
l'enfance qualifie cette situation de
génocide et donne le chiffre de 12
millions d'enfants
[Musique]
21h30 heure française merci nous
rejoindre en direct sur rt france le
coronavirus continue donc sa propagation
avec plus de cent dix mille personnes
contaminées dans le monde désormais deux
premiers décès en allemagne chypre à son
tour touchée aujourd'hui tous les pays
de l'union européenne sont concernés
quinze mille personnes concernées au
total les mesures pour contrer
l'épidémie se multiplient en france le
ministère annonce quatre nouveaux décès
portant le total à 25 et 1412 qu'a
confirmé le ministre de la culture
franck riester a été testé positif on a
appris ce soir mais serai en forme
d'après son cabinet plus tôt dans la
journée la ministre des sports a
souligné l'importance du huit clos dans
les événements sportifs tout en
rappelant l'interdiction des
rassemblements de plus de 1000 personnes
on écoute jérôme cèderont ce jour à 15h
selon santé publique france nous avons
1412 cas confirmés soit 286 de plus qui
hier nous avons aujourd'hui un nouveau
regroupement de cas c'est en corse à
ajaccio et la corse signal 38 cas nous
avons une évolution probablement
inéluctable difficilement évitable vers
une épidémie mais une demeure de
nombreuses incertitudes d'abord sur le
comportement du virus et surtout sur
l'impact des mesures barrières et
individuelle et collective que nous
mettons en place plus de 1000 tests sont
réalisés par jour avec des capacités
largement supérieur des laboratoires le
plan bleu a été activé au plan national
dans tous les établissements
médico-sociaux je le rappelle ce soir la
très grande majorité des formes de la
maladie sont bénignes
ainsi les agences régionales de santé
sont en mesure de décider en lien avec
les professionnels de santé de ville qui
sont des acteurs clés un suivi à
domicile des personnes ne présentant pas
de forme sévère de la maladie et europe
a passé aujourd'hui le cap des 500 décès
liés aux coronavirus avec 97 nouveaux
morts en 24 heures en italie le pays
deuxième foyer dans le monde
épidémie met en place des mesures
drastiques 15 millions d'habitants sont
en quarantaine une mesure de contrer
finement prévu jusqu'au 3 avril elle
concerne une vaste zone dans le nord du
pays
il s'agit là d'une mesure inédite en
europe les précisions avec leila sarah
fait clément hospital des supermarchés
pris d'assaut faso coronavirus en zone
rouge italienne les habitants vivent
tant bien que mal au rythme de la
quarantaine
rome a placé sous cloche une grande
partie du nord de l'italie pour tenter
de contenir l'épidémie
les rues sont désertes les gares et les
aéroports sont vides
la population s'est résigné à vivre au
ralenti nous avons des mesures correctes
pour maintenir la sécurité autant que
possible nous allons donc de l'avant de
manière responsable
on espère on en sortir le plus tôt
possible la vie a déjà bien couche en ga
piazza depuis ce matin car le décret
gouvernemental a déjà modifié les
habitudes des citoyens
il ya moins de monde les bars sont
nombreux ce sont les signes d'un grand
changement modifications mais tout le
monde ne partage pas cette vision depuis
dimanche des mutineries ont éclaté dans
les prisons du pays
en cause les mesures contre la
propagation du virus comme l'arrêt des
visites simorre déjà à modène et ce
lundi à milan la famille des détenus en
est venu aux mains avec les forces de
police
cela dépend de plein de choses je suis
convaincu que le virus est partout en
italie les restrictions appliquées
uniquement milan me sont donc stupide je
suis quelqu un voyage c'est probablement
sans mauvaise intention
ils ne sont qu'un probable que cette
personne se met en danger
pauli jusqu'à du diamant l'épidémie
provoque aussi l'exode de nombreux
habitants pour rejoindre d'autres
régions d'italie
le gouvernement cherche à rassurer pour
éviter que la situation n'empire
il n'y a pas de régions d'italie qui
soit complètement immunisé
il y à des parties de l'italie où le
virus circule actuellement - mais le
fait que le virus circule dépend de
notre comportement
la mesure touche le poumon économique de
l'italie et sa capitale milan où vivent
plus de 15 millions d'habitants
les restrictions drastiques
s'appliqueront au moins jusqu'au 3 avril
prochain et c'est donc de la chine que
tout est parti premier foyer mondial de
l'épidémie le pays sort et emmenés en
moins peu à peu vers un retour à la
normale selon l' oms plus de 70 % des
malades en chine on guérit l'iran en
revanche peine à freiner l'épidémie le
pays recense aujourd'hui 43 décès
supplémentaires 237 personnes sont
mortes du virus
l aéroport 10 par an la température des
passagers vérifiées et l intérieur des
avions
tout est désinfecté ailleurs dont
également on prend des mesures
drastiques interdiction des
rassemblements écoles et crèches fermées
en fonction des pays et parfois en
quarantaine regarder
t
[Musique]
alors comment réagir face à cette
épidémie alors que l'italie a passé 15
millions de personnes en quarantaine la
france elle aussi doit prendre des
mesures quelles sont-elles dont elles
suivent les entre l'exemple transalpin
quelle est la marge de manoeuvre des
gouvernements sur le plan de la santé
publique mais aussi sur la question de
l'économie c'est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir et pour en débattre nous
sommes en direct avec le docteur laurent
alexandre entrepreneur et essayiste
bonsoir le docteur laurent alexandre
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france sur ce plateau à paris ferghana
ziari chargé d'études pour l'institut de
recherches économiques et fiscales merci
alors vous d'être là aussi à leur
première question messieurs votre
réaction un petit peu globale sur ce
climat assez irréaliste en ce moment
docteur à laurent alexandre ben c'est un
virus nouveau
c'est à dire que nous ne connaissons pas
encore la vie et les us et coutumes de
ce virus notamment nous ne savons pas si
le coronavirus va se calmer quand il
fait plus chaud
d'habitude les virus respiratoires
s'améliore lorsque la température
augmente et lorsqu elle est juive est
arrivé lorsqu'il ya plus de soleil mais
on n'en est pas certain pour le corps
d'un virus donc on est face à une grande
incertitude
ce qui explique que la position du
ministère de la santé ne soit pas facile
pour vous on n'en fait pas trop c'est
normal d'avoir finalement aussi peur
parce que il semblerait que la psychose
gagnent peu à peu c'est en tout cas
l'impression qu'on en a quand on allume
sa télé le matin alors il est normal de
prendre des démesures puisqu'il n'y a
pas de vaccin contre le port navires us
pour l'instant il n'y a pas non plus de
médicaments donc la seule façon d'éviter
qu'ils gens la trappe c'est de limiter
les contacts donc ce que fait le
ministère de la santé en france et me
paraît tout à fait raisonnable est ce
que fait le ministre de la santé
olivier derand et est aujourd'hui
l'optimum
il faut gagner du temps on n'aura pas
un contre le coronavirus avant de
nombreux mois donc il faut aujourd'hui
prendre en charge les malades et
notamment les malades les plus fragiles
les plus graves
et puis il faut éviter que les gens se
contaminent comme dans toute infection
virale
quand vous dites il faut gagner du temps
pourquoi est ce aussi important de
gagner du temps justement pour avoir le
temps de me trouver des remèdes un
vaccin que vous évoquez surtout parce
que en hiver les places dans les
services de pneumologie et dans les
services de réanimation sont utilisés
pour les gens qui font des pneumonies et
notamment pour les personnes âgées par
exemple à la suite d'un épisode grippal
nous qu'on ne peut pas gérer facilement
en même temps l'embolisation des
hôpitaux par les grippes crabe et puis
par le coronavirus faut savoir qu'en
france la grippe fait dix mille morts
chaque année il y a donc de nombreuses
places en cardiologie en pneumologie et
dans les services de réanimation qui
sont utilisées par des malades qui ont
eu une grippe grave quand on arrive au
printemps les la grippe diminue et donc
il ya plus de places en réanimation pour
les malades qui ont un coronavirus donc
à plusieurs mesures qui ont été
annoncées pour la france en tant qu un
huis clos pour les matchs concerts
annulés rassemblement de plus de 1000
personnes proscrit ça vous paraît trop
la bonne solution ferghana ziane c'est
une question assez difficile parce que
laurent alexandre l'a rappelé il ya
beaucoup d'incertitudes sur ce virus et
ça pose la question des risques qu'on
est prêt à prendre
en fait c'est à dire que le problème
c'est que l'aversion au risque est
quelque chose de subjectif certaines
personnes seront très insouciante et
continueront à vivre malgré le risque
d'être contaminé d'autres beaucoup plus
fragiles seront beaucoup plus frileux et
considérons que le moindre risque est
tout à fait intolérable et préférons
donc ceux restés confinés
pour ma part je ne suis pas médecin donc
je vais pas me prononcer sur les
questions de santé
mais c'est vrai que à titre personnel je
suis assez réticent à l'idée qu'il
faille s'arrêter de vivre
en raison de cette épidémie mais encore
une fois cela relève aussi de la
perception individuelle avoir une fois
ce l'aversion au risque est trop
subjective
certaines personnes vont préférer vont
continuer à vivre et vont prendre le
risque de s'exposer s'il la trappe et
bien ceux là relèvera aussi de leur
responsabilité individuelle et d'autres
préféreront être plus prudent je pense
que c'est à chacun de prendre ses
responsabilités ici en fonction de sa
santé est effectivement les personnes
âgées les gens qui ont des pathologies
et serait d'être plus responsable pour
elle de limiter leurs déplacements de
rester chez elle essaie de sortir le
moins possible et a contrario inverse
ceux qui peuvent se le permettre on peut
pas non plus bloquer tout un pays tout
une économie
ça aurait des répercussions sur la vie
des gens qui pourraient être encore plus
problématique si les gens ne peuvent
plus subvenir à leurs besoins c'est
quelque chose de tout aussi
problématique que qu'une sap est aussi
assez grave
ça veut dire que nous on doit prendre
nos responsabilités en tant que citoyen
vous attendez beaucoup vous par exemple
du gouvernement ces mesures
voilà ces empêchements les gens qui
voulaient aller au concert au match est
ce que c'est une bonne chose
de les interdire justement parce que là
c'est pas prendre ses responsabilités
c'est le gouvernement qui oui ils sont
en train les c'est vrai que le
gouvernement alors le gouvernement dans
une position délicate parce que il est
poussé par l'opinion publique à réagir
de manière ferme puisque a posteriori si
il ne prend pas ces mesures
il sera accusé par les populations de ne
pas avoir fait grand chose il ya un
billet toujours pro action qui fait que
même si on n'est pas certain de
l'efficacité de telle ou telle mesure où
il faut quand même la prendre pour
satisfaire les opinions publiques
ceci dit il faut pas non plus verser
dans l'hystérie il faut être aussi sûr
que les mesures que l'on prend ne ne
rajoute pas des problèmes
supplémentaires et de mesures qui me
vient à l'esprit c'est la volonté
d'interdire de plafonner les prix
notamment des gels hydroalcooliques
alors bruno le maire a pris cette mesure
de manière assez énergétique pour
montrer qu'il fait quelque chose
mais économistes vous disent tous que
lorsqu'il ya une offre qui qui est
limitée une demande qui explose
plafonner les prix ça ne sert
strictement à rien vous allez juste
créer la pénurie supplémentaires et
rendre ses produits la moins accessible
encore pour les populations
donc voilà typiquement un jeu une ce
genre de mesure complètement démagogique
qui ne sert à rien si ce n'est à
accélérer les pénuries dans les
pharmacies et qui va peut-être contenter
les les opinions qui attend des
gouvernements qu'ils agissent très
activement sans pour autant observé un
quelconque effet positif sur la santé
des populations
laurent alexandre vous avez salué
l'action du miso la santé mais alors
voilà typiquement ce genre de mesure
vous vous êtes en accord avec vraiment
toutes les mesures annoncées par le
gouvernement
monsieur a dit harry vous parlez nous
parler de ces gels mans fayat jeu le
site est plus haut
l'interdiction des matchs des concerts
des racines une 1000 personnes on est
dans la bonne voie en effet sans un sou
oui alors je suis d'accord avec ses
organes de play ce n'est le prix est
jeune ça va juste conduit au marché noir
des gels comme d'habitude parce que s'il
ya une demande très forte et qu'on
bloque les prix bas n'y en aura pas pour
tout le monde donc ça c'est une mesure
qui est effectivement démagogique
les mesures qui ont été prises par le
ministère de la santé et par le
gouvernement pour limiter
et les rencontres très de foule
nombreuse sont raisonnables c'est une
limitation à nos libertés mais qui
n'était que temporaire
personnellement je les approuve ce que
je voudrais dire sur ce virus et qu' il
faut raison garder entre 1900 et 1977 de
l'éradication sur terre de la variole la
variole a tué 300 millions de personnes
chaque année avant le vaccin la rougeole
tué six millions d'enfants sur terre le
sida a tué 36 millions de personnes sur
terre la grippe les années où elle est
un peu forte tue un million de personnes
sur terre et en 1919 elle a tué entre 50
et 100 millions de personnes donc le
coronavirus n'est pas un virus qui pour
l'instant a entraîné des désastres aussi
important que les grandes pandémies
virale du 20e siècle et surtout cette
pandémie ne change rien l'idée que le
monde ne serait pas plus sûr et en
meilleure santé s'ils étaient fermés moi
je mets ferait davantage de la démagogie
de ceux qui nous expliquent
qu'aujourd'hui que on n'aurait jamais dû
s'ouvrir comme un certain nationale et
que les perturbations sur les chaînes
d'approvisionnement
ce serait là la prétendue preuve qu'il
ne fallait jamais entretenir des liens
de dépendance aussi fort à l'égard de
l'étranger mais au contraire si les
maladies que je viens de citer
laurent alexandre font aujourd'hui aussi
peu de victimes et ont commencé à
reculer au cours du 20e siècle c'est
précisément grâce à l'ouverture du
commerce grâce au fait que la
mondialisation à consolider une
industrie pharmaceutique et médical
productive capable de mettre aujourd'hui
à disposition à l'échelle massive des
médicaments et cela n'aurait pas été
possible simplement dans un contexte de
tharsis je crois qu'il faut être assez
démagogique pour ne pas dire
complètement idiot pour dire que la
corée du nord aujourd'hui serait dans un
état sanitaire beaucoup plus enviable au
motif qu'elle est fermée contrairement
aux autres pays
du monde si oui tout fair ghana a tout à
fait raison
la corée du nord montre ce qu'est un
pays qui ferme ses frontières si nous
fermions en nos frontières nous serions
tous très pauvre et nous aurions la
médecine des années 1930 et nous prendre
en ayant énormément de risques donc les
gens qui proposent la fermeture des
frontières les gens qui proposent la fin
du commerce international en réalité
nous propose de nous appauvrir et de
nous conduire à une époque pour ne
savaient pas traiter les dix russes où
on ne s'arrête pas traiter les
infections
c'est bien parce que le commerce
international nous a enrichis et à
développer la technologie notamment
médicale qu'on est obligé où on est
aujourd'hui plus serein face aux
coronavirus qu'on l'était jadis face à
la variole et surtout l'idée qu'il
faille tout simplement réduire notre
dépendance à l'égard de l'étranger sous
sous-entend que notre pays serait par
essence immunisé contre l'imprévu ce qui
est là encore complètement idiot demandé
aux africains de l'est qui actuellement
voir le voient leurs récoltes ravagés
par des nuées de criquets s'il faut
qu'ils s'abstiennent de toute dépendance
extérieure
c'est précisément grâce au commerce que
ces gens pourront importer les dorés qui
leur manquent à l'échelle locale à cause
de l'imprévisible donc le risque zéro
n'existe nulle part et n'existe ni dans
les sociétés ouvertes néracais faire le
vide et puis d'acheter des pesticides
parce que contre les criquets la seule
chose qu'on sait faire ce sont les
pesticides
ce n'est pas l'agriculture bio qui va
permettre de lutter contre les criquets
alors il n'empêche messieurs ça ne vous
a évidemment pas échappé les marchés
accuser les plongeons monstre a
aujourd'hui en tout cas comparables à
ceux de 2008
est ce que ce n'est pas là justement une
façon de peut-être de changer certains
en tout cas de remettre en cause notre
modèle est ce qu'on n'est pas trop
dépendants effectivement de certains
pays comme la chine cette fébrilité
économique ne vous inquiétez pas vous
elle est temporaire c'est à dire que on
a effectivement nous et d
interdépendance avec de nombreux pays du
monde dont la chine les chaînes
d'approvisionnement sont aujourd'hui
perturbé à cause de cette pandémie
mais lorsque cet épisode sera derrière
nous je pense et je suis certain que ces
chaînes vont se reconstituer c'est à
dire que quand une fois on a toujours
intérêt à l'ouverture
l' avantage aussi du libre échange c'est
la capacité à diversifier les sources
d'approvisionnement donc s'ouvrir et se
rendre dépendant du monde ne veut pas
dire perdre tout résilience si aussi la
capacité pour les firmes de relocaliser
temporairement leurs chaînes
d'approvisionnement
c'est lent c'est laborieux ça ne se fait
pas comme ça d'un claquement de doigts
mais c'est possible
moi je suis convaincu encore une fois
que lorsque toute cette pandémie sera
derrière nous à les entreprises
relocaliseront parce que cette
internationalisation de la division du
travail
elle correspond aussi à la demande des
consommateurs des demandes de produits à
des prix toujours plus faibles ceux ci
se prive de ce commerce national
inutilement pour des raisons
irrationnelle seront totalement balayés
par la concurrence de ceux qui géreront
leur chaîne d'approvisionnement
plus raisonnablement en
localisant les productions là où elles
sont les plus optimales treloar
alexandre je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec ce qu'a dit c'est regarde moi je
voudrais donner un message d'optimisme
en 1348
quand la grande peste est arrivée elle a
tué en cours 40% des européens
quatre européens sur dix sont mort de la
peste et il n'y avait pas de traitement
vu le premier traitement contre la peste
et la tétracycline en 1948 c'est à dire
six cents ans plus tard les gens
rentrent et 148 quand la peste est
arrivé il leur fallait six siècles pour
avoir un traitement
donc évidemment il allait mourir sans
traitement alors que nous savons
aujourd'hui que nous aurons un
traitement contre le coronavirus au
maximum dans deux ans c'est intéressant
ce que vous nous dites déjà vous nous
apprenez plein de choses premièrement et
deuxièmement ça veut dire qu'on est dans
des sociétés aujourd'hui qui n'accepte
plus le risque on demande à nos
gouvernements de gérer finalement le
risque zéro tout à l'heure vous 7
juillet l'action du gouvernement mais
c'est vrai que voilà il ya beaucoup de
sueur sur réaction on n'accepte plus
justement les risques aujourd'hui on est
des sales gosses on est des enfants
gâtés
et puis les collabos log les écologistes
du prophète de malheur nous ont
convaincus que nous vivons une époque
affreuse alors que l'espérance de vie et
la santé sur terre n'a jamais été aussi
bonne
en 1900 l'espérance de vie sur terre
était de moins de 30 ans elle est
aujourd'hui de 71 ans donc nous n'avons
jamais sur terre une aussi bonne santé
aujourd'hui donc il faut relativiser le
color au nadi russe mym ce même si c'est
une épreuve médical pour pour la terre
la terre ne s'est jamais aussi bien
porté en termes de qualité de santé
d'espérance de vie
la mortalité à la naissance n'a jamais
été aussi faible
la mentalité des enfants n'a jamais été
aussi faible la mortalité par
catastrophe naturelle n'a jamais été
aussi faible
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que le nombre
de morts par catastrophe naturelle a été
divisée par nuit là depuis l'année 1931
donc oui l'état de santé en 2020 et très
bon par rapport à ce qu'il était dans le
passé donc il ne faut pas insulter
la médecine d'aujourd'hui la médecine
d'aujourd'hui c'est que nous avons
beaucoup beaucoup moins de maladies que
nous vivons beaucoup plus longtemps
qu'avant donc ne jouons pas les sales
gosses tu les sales gosses ingrat
remercions la médecine de serre que nous
n'avons jamais eu une meilleure santé
sur terre quand cette année 2020 et
c'est vrai que on aime bien fantasmer la
terre comme une espèce de jardin d'éden
qui n'a jamais été qui n'a jamais existé
c'est à dire que c'est vraiment une
attitude très rousseauiste de penser que
la terre serait à l'état de nature havre
comme ça naturellement hospitalier et
que tous les maux de la terre
proviennent de la civilisation de la
mondialisation des interdépendances de
l'industrialisation des voix écologistes
se sont levés pour accuser
l'artificialisation du monde d'exposer
l'humanité à des maladies qui
n'existerait pas alors ce qu'on sente
ici la nature sauvage donc les victimes
du paludisme à la périphérie des pays
qui ont asséché leurs zones humides
seront ravis d'apprendre qui a séché que
sanctuariser la nature sauvage suffit à
la rendre bienveillante
non la terre n'a jamais été cet éden
hospitalier c'est au contraire la
civilisation le progrès l'ouverture qui
permet d'alléger le fardeau terrestre de
l'homme et de faire en sorte en effet
que notre espèce n'est jamais été aussi
bonne santé
aujourd'hui vous parler d'écologie le
fameux nuage de pollution qui est
traditionnellement au dessus de la chine
a semble-t-il disparu ces dernières
semaines
y'a pas de leçons à tirer de ce constat
je pense que c'est une vision assez
cynique c'est à dire que la pollution
c'est la contrepartie inévitable de la
vie c'est à dire que chaque activité
humaine implique un certain degré de
pollution qu'on va juger plus ou moins
acceptable en fonction des circonstances
de l'époque des technologies disponibles
de notre niveau de richesse dire se
féliciter comme on a pu l'entendre de
d'une réduction de la pollution sans
comprendre qu'il s'agit là de la
contrepartie de l'arrêt d'industrie qui
permettent à des gens de vivre une vie
confortable
je pense que c'est d'un cynisme est
intolérable et assainissement c'est
assez oui assez assez
c'est révoltant laurent alexandre
cynisme révoltant vous aussi vous
partagez cet avis les gens juste oublié
ce qu'était la vie jadis l'espérance de
vie à paris elle était de 25 ans 25 ans
et louis 14 a perdu sa dernière devant à
42 ans la vie de son patient était
absolument vous épouvantable et les gens
l'ont oublié avant la vaccination contre
la polio quand on avait son gamin qui
avait la polio on le mettait dans un
piment artificielle 7 est absolument
atroce et le plus souvent son gamin
mouret on ne réalise plus l'opinion ne
réalisent pas à quel point la vie était
difficile dans le passé et aujourd'hui
les gens ferghana raison les gens
réalisent un passé qui était
épouvantable la vie dans le passé est
épouvantable il n'y avait pas y avait
pas d'antalgiques on mourait très
facilement de maladie il faut savoir par
exemple qu avant l'invention de
l'appendicectomie en 1888 à lausanne par
le docteur charles kraft sont pour ce
temps des gens qui avaient une
appendicite aiguë mouren et quand on
avait son gamin qui avait une
appendicite
on appelait pas le médecin on appelait
le croque mort et le curé jusqu'en 1888
donc n'idéalisons pas le passé
heureusement nous vivons en 2020 la vie
n'a jamais été aussi douce qu'en 2020
nous allons arriver à contourner la
problématique du coronavirus on va
trouver un traitement et si nous étions
cinquante ans plus tôt je serais inquiet
pour le corps d'un virus mais avec la
technologie de 2020 nous allons
rapidement limité les dégâts puis
trouver des solutions radicales
vive le progrès et vive la médecine et
en tant que médecin je ne souhaite à
personne je ne souhaite à aucun français
de vivre dans la france 2009 de 1930 ou
de 1950
parce que la médecine y était très
rudimentaire merci on va terminer sur
ces paroles positives ça fait du bien
n'est ce pas merci docteur laurent
alexandre d'avoir été en direct avec
nous merci
sur ce plateau fergane
ziri asa à pardon a dit harish je vais y
arriver vraiment été avec nous également
un cdh afin de cette émission se
retrouve dans 5 minutes pour 1 point
complet sur l'actualité
[Musique]
en inde il n'existe pas de statistiques
officielles sur les enfants perdus ou
séparés de leurs parents
selon certaines informations un enfant
disparaît toutes les huit minutes dans
le pays
cet enfant est avec vous ou allez vous
[Musique]
elle est avec toi et lui
il est aussi avec toi il vous accompagne
je ne sais pas je connais pas son nom
selon la commission nationale des droits
de l'homme 44 mille mineurs
disparaissent chaque année
la police déclare qu ils sont 88 mille
enfants le fonds des nations unies pour
l'enfance qualifie cette situation de
génocide et donne le chiffre de 12
millions d'enfants
ce
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
j'ai entendu parler de wikileaks et de
julian assange pour la première fois
quand j'ai vu les images filmées depuis
l'hélicoptère en irak a tiré et je pense
qu'il ya des gens dans l'armée
américaine qui ne lui ont jamais
pardonné
je ne suis pas pour la peine de mort et
puisque je ne suis pas pour la peine de
mort il n'a qu'une chose à faire abattre
ce fils de [ __ ] illégalement et oasis et
est historique il n'est pas d'avoir un
journaliste indépendant
un type avec son ordinateur révélant des
crimes de guerre à un large public
l'idée de développer une boîte de dépôts
numériques anonyme en lien avec le média
qu'est wikileaks
c'est une vraie nouveauté est sauf
mais je n'avais pas prévu qu'il
deviendra célèbre dans le monde entier
si vite qu'il serait à la tête de l'une
des plus puissantes organisations
médiatiques du monde avait il avait
beaucoup de jalousie dans l'immédiat
traditionnelle envers wikileaks est en
vert assange en particulier pourquoi
n'est-il pas plus comme nous ils vont
accuser d'étaler des excréments sur les
murs roses
ce qui est fou
et a dû rouler un julian assange est à
l' isolement dans une prison de haute
sécurité attendant peut-être une
sentence d'emprisonnement à perpétuité
alors je ne veux pas le voir mourir dans
une prison américaine à l'infini et je
crois que c'est le sort qui l'attend est
très saine
[Musique]
ici on l'appelle la tour de david et
pour beaucoup de gens c'est l'endroit le
plus sûr de la capitale du venezuela
pourtant célèbre pour des taux de
criminalité urbaine très élevé 2500
personnes sans abri ont occupé ce
gratte-ciel inachevé du centre de
caracas
ils en ont chassé les criminels et
organiser leur propre coopérative
d'habitation
[Musique]
m
l'épidémie de corona virus continue de
se propager en france quatre nouveaux
décès portant le total à 25 morts et
plus de mille 400 cas confirmés dont
deux ministres de la culture font que
riester qui dit se porter bien ce soir
l'italie c'est en étant dans la
quarantaine à l'ensemble du pays la
menace d'une pandémie est devenu très
réelles selon l' oms le président turc
chez hyper doan demande à l'otan son
soutien concret dans le conflit en syrie
lors d'une visite à bruxelles
aujourd'hui les négociations se tiennent
en ce moment entre l'europe et la
turquie a décidé d'ouvrir ses frontières
avec la grèce à plusieurs milliers de
réfugiés pour l'afghanistan
l'organisation état islamique revendique
une double explosion à kaboul roman
menda signature d'un accord de paix avec
les talibans
attentat qui a eu lieu ce matin pendant
les cérémonies d'investiture
présidentielle concurrents tous deux
responsables disent endosser la fonction
de président
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
et vous nous rejoignez le coronavirus
continue sa propagation avec plus de
cent dix mille personnes chypre est à
son tour touchée aujourd'hui tous les
pays de l'union européenne sont
concernés les mesures pour contrer
l'épidémie se multiplient en france le
bilan fait état de 25 décès plus de 1400
qu'a confirmé le ministre de la santé
franck leicester a été testé positif
mais serai en forme d'après son cabinet
plus tôt dans la journée la ministre des
sports a souligné l'importance du huis
clos dans les événements sportifs tout
en rappelant l'interdiction des
rassemblements de plus de 1000 personnes
on écoute jérôme salomon ce jour à 15h
selon santé publique france nous avons
1412 cas confirmés soit 286 de plus qui
hier nous avons aujourd'hui un nouveau
regroupement de cas c'est en corse à
ajaccio et la corse signal 38 cas nous
avons une évolution probablement
inéluctable difficilement évitable
verrines épidémie mais il demeure de
nombreuses incertitudes d'abord sur le
comportement du virus et surtout soit
l'impact des mesures barrières et
individuelle et collective que nous
mettons en place plus de 1000 tests sont
réalisés par jour avec des capacités
largement supérieur des laboratoires le
plan bleu a été activé au plan national
dans tous les établissements
médico-sociaux je le rappelle ce soir la
très grande majorité des formes de la
maladie sont bénignes
ainsi les agences régionales de santé
sont en mesure de décider en lien avec
les professionnels de santé de ville qui
sont des acteurs clés un suivi à
domicile des personnes ne présentant pas
de forme sévère de la maladie
d'après les mesures prises par le
gouvernement vendredi aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron a pris la parole le
président de la république souhaite
davantage de coordination au niveau
européen les 27 dirigeants participeront
demain probablement dans l'après midi à
une visioconférence écoute je souhaite
qu'on ait plus de coordination
européenne et internationale et
j'annoncerai des initiatives dès cet
après midi en la matière il est
important que nous ayons une réponse qui
correspond à la nature du risque vu par
les scientifiques est telle qu'ils nous
informent que cette réponse permettent
de freiner l'épidémie
est ce que nous sommes en train de faire
et qu'elle soit toujours guidé par la
science est proportionné et parmi les
nouveaux cas de cordes à vis à vis en
france cinq députés et le patron des dp
il est difficile pour les français de se
positionner doivent-ils avoir peur de
l'épidémie ou au contraire ne pas céder
à la panique générale 15 est qu'est
médecin urgentiste chroniqueur s'il ya
un clé tude c'est à cause de la
surmédiatisation selon lui il les
mesures actuellement qui sont prises qui
sont d'ordre justification sanitaire
mais qui ont des conséquences
économiques et politiques même en l
âpreté ces élections municipales en tant
que médecin et je suis pas le seul à le
penser on a vraiment l'impression qu'on
en fait énormément sur le coronavirus
oui c'est un virus qui va tuer qui va
tuer les personnes les plus fragiles
mais j'allais dire comme la grippe
chaque année dans l'indifférence
générale devant l'indifférence générale
vous avez dix mille morts par an en
plein pic d'épidémie les 170 morts par
jour est ce qu'on en fait le décompte
est ce qu'on prend toutes ces mesures
les autres année alors que généralement
on dénonce justement le manque de moyens
à l'hôpital par exemple
non alors pourquoi cette année il ya ce
lot de mesures il ya ce décompte
anxiogène on peut se poser on peut se
poser la question et puis surtout nous
ce qui nous inquiète c'est les
phénomènes de panique de psychose
générale d'hystérie collective et il
faudrait pas qu'on arrive à les troubles
à l'ordre public qui serait plus
embêtant que quand la virus finalement
il n'aura pas à passer aujourd'hui de
quatre des cinq cents décès liés au
corps navires us avec quatre heures dix
sept nouveaux morts en 24 heures en
italie le pays mette en place des
mesures drastiques ce soir le
gouvernement donne aux italiens d'éviter
les déplacements étant la quarantaine à
l'ensemble du pays on apprend que le
championnat de football est totalement
suspendu
confinement donc prévu jusqu'au 3 avril
il s'agit là d'une mesure inédite en
europe précision avec elle et la sarre a
fait clémence pital des supermarchés
pris d'assaut faso coronavirus en zone
rouge italienne les habitants vivent
tant bien que mal au rythme de la
quarantaine rome a placé sous cloche une
grande partie du nord de l'italie pour
tenter de contenir l'épidémie
les rues sont désertes les gares et les
aéroports sont vides
la population s'est résigné à vivre au
ralenti nous avons des mesures corée
pour maintenir la sécurité autant que
possible nous allons donc de l'avant de
manière responsable
on espère on en sortir le plus tôt
possible la vie a déjà bien changé à pia
senza depuis ce matin car le décret
gouvernemental a déjà modifié les
habitudes des citoyens
il ya moins de monde les bars on envoie
des primes ce sont les signes d'un grand
changement gothique mais tout le monde
ne partage pas cette vision depuis
dimanche des mutineries ont éclaté dans
les prisons du pays
en cause les mesures contre la
propagation du virus comme l'arrêt des
visites simorre déjà à modène et ce
lundi à milan la famille des détenus en
est venu aux mains avec les forces de
police
cela dépend de plein de choses je suis
convaincu que le virus est partout en
italie les restrictions appliquées
uniquement à milan me sont donc stupide
c'est quelqu'un voyage c'est
probablement sans mauvaise intention
il ne semble donc improbable que cette
personne se met en danger
pour lui jusqu'à du diamant l'épidémie
provoque aussi l'exode de nombreux
habitants pour rejoindre d'autres
régions d'italie
le gouvernement cherche à rassurer pour
éviter que la situation n'empire
il n'y a pas de régions d'italie qui
soit complètement
il ya des parties de l'italie où le
virus circule actuellement - mais le
fait que le virus circule dépend de
notre comportement
la mesure touche le poumon économique de
l'italie et sa capitale milan où vivent
plus de 15 millions d'habitants
les restrictions drastiques
s'appliqueront au moins jusqu'au 3 avril
prochain et pour météo g7 berti
rédacteur en chef des médias putsch les
mesures de quarantaine aurait dû être
prise plus tôt d'abord l'italie est
fortement interconnectés avec par
exemple la france mais aussi avec les
autres pays européens notamment
l'allemagne
et si le poumon économique item bien
s'arrête il faut considérer qu'elle par
exemple il ya des gars en or française
vient de forte participation
les banques italiennes je pense
personnellement que on devait arriver
avant à ces mesures de filtrage ou de
quarantaine de blocage peut être pu être
plus limité après je ne suis pas un
médecin mais ce que je constate depuis
puis si à travers les médias et les
témoignages que je reçois des mes amis
et de ma famille je suis préoccupé parce
que je ne sais pas combien de temps ça
va en france à la bourse de paris a
accusé aujourd'hui sa pire chute sur une
séance depuis près de douze oran -8 39%
selon renaud lemaire la croissance
française a été impactée par le
coronavirus avec un premier trimestre en
demi-teinte
le ministre de l'économie et des
finances participer à une réunion
d'urgence ce matin il a évoqué les
secteurs en difficulté dont d'avoir les
premiers chiffres du trimestre 2020 qui
montrent que l'économie française
s'était bien redresser au premier mois
de janvier 2020 preuve que l'économie
française repose sur des bases stables
mais en revanche dès la mi-février a
fortiori
début mars nous voyons un impact très
directe de l'épidémie de couronnes à
virus sur notre économie
je donnerai nouvelles évaluations
chiffrées lors de la présentation des
prévisions du pacte de stabilité
c'est-à-dire le 15 avril
vous aurez une nouvelle prévision
chiffrée de croissance française mais je
le redis
l'impact se chiffrera en plusieurs
dixièmes de points de pib pour
l'économie française
si on regarde secteur par secteur on
voit bien que un certain nombre de
secteurs sont très durement touchée et
l'impact et violents pour ces secteurs
qui étaient présents ce matin je vous
donne quelques chiffres qui vont été
donnée par les professionnels dédiés à
quelques instants c'est des baisses de
chiffre d'affaires de 60 % en moyenne
pour les créateurs de 30 à 40% dans
l'hôtellerie de 25% en moyenne pour les
restaurateurs et des chiffres encore
plus fort pour tout le secteur de
l'événementiel puisque les des
animations se font aujourd'hui en
cascade dans ce secteur-là l'épidémie de
coronavirus aura un impact sévère sur
l'économie française qui se chiffrera en
plusieurs dixièmes de points de pib
durant l'année 2020 avec les craintes
liées aux coronavirus la chute des cours
du pétrole vient plomber également le
cac40 de pétrole qui termine en baisse
de 25% à new york à 31,13 dollars le
baril et des cours qui s'effondre après
l'échec des négociations entre la russie
et l'opep l'organisation des pays
exportateurs de pétrole l'arabie
saoudite dessine de baisser ses prix
pour essayer de relancer la demande la
plus importante réduction de ces prix
est relié depuis vingt ans et on fait le
point sur ses conséquences économiques
avec mona hameau dès lors depuis des
semaines tout le monde ne parle que de
ça le coronavirus représente une urgence
de santé publique mais aussi une menace
pour la croissance puisque la crise
provoquée par l'épidémie frappe de plein
fouet l'économie mondiale qui se dirige
tout droit vers une récession
les principales bourses d'asie et suit
le lot
de pertes victime de la propagation du
virus mais aussi de l'effondrement du
marché du pétrole les cours de l'or noir
qui ont connu ce lundi leur pire chute
depuis la première guerre du golfe en 91
se sont effondrées de plus de 30 % en
asie une crise due en partie au conflit
entre la russie et l'arabie saoudite
deux des trois plus gros producteurs
mondiaux et face à la chute de la
consommation ces derniers n'ont pas
réussi à s'entendre pour réduire leur
production
une réunion de crise a eu lieu avec les
13 pays de l'organisation des pays
exportateurs de pétrole et moscou elle
s'est opposée à une nouvelle réduction d
1,5 million de barils par jour et a donc
décidé de faire cavalier seul et en
réponse à cela et bien ryad a déclenché
une véritable guerre des prix entraînant
la chute des cours du brut
alors pour vous donner une idée des
conséquences sur les coûts on est
actuellement à 35 dollars le baril de
pétrole contre 70 dollars juste avant
l'épidémie prenait la chine par exemple
qui est le premier consommateur de brut
mondial 14 % de la demande soit 14
millions de barils par jour l'europe
n'est pas épargnée elle et bourses du
continent sont également en chute libre
et tout le monde ya droit lé pays avec
une économie fragile vont en pâtir les
premiers le venezuela l'algérie l'iran
ou encore le nigeria qui risque de
basculer dans des crises économiques et
sociales à cause d'un prix du brut qui
s'effondrent les mesures saoudienne sur
le prix du pétrole pourrait donc avoir
un rôle crucial dans la crise économique
mondiale vers laquelle nous nous
dirigeons peut-être est selon tom loin
gault économiste la chute du cours du
pétrole pose surtout le problème aux
producteurs tout à fait le problème avec
une baisse brutale des prix du pétrole
c'est que le marché sont structurées
autour du prix présent
donc les contrats présents et futurs
sont basés sur ce prix et si la marge
baisse alors les contrats en souffre
beaucoup de personnes perdent beaucoup
d'argent
le problème plus important c'est pour
les producteurs de pétrole et les
répercussions pour ces personnes qui ne
peuvent pas absorber beaucoup de dettes
les personnes qui les sociétés qui ont
beaucoup de dettes ne lui font pas se
permettre de continuer de continuer à
produire avec ses prix cela aura des
répercussions sur les banques qui ont
prêté l'argent et cela mènera à des
effets de cascades sur le marché c'est
ce que l'on commence à observer
aujourd'hui avec la baisse des actions
les personnes essayent de d'acheter de
l'or par exemple
recep tayyip erdogan et à bruxelles en
ce moment aidé à donner une conférence
de presse commune avec le secrétaire
général de l'otan jens stoltenberg
le président turc a insisté sur le
soutien total et sans condition que
l'otan doit apporter à la turquie on
écoute
nous sommes le seul pays de l'otan qui
luttent contre tech homme à homme et qui
a sacrifié défi nous accueillons
également 3,7 millions de réfugiés
syriens
à l'avenir nous voulons un soutien
concret de nos alliés la turquie mène ce
combat seul jusqu'à présent au prix de
grands sacrifices l'otan vit une période
charnière elle devrait faire la preuve
d'une solidarité profonde à écouter à
présent est en stand by le secrétaire
général de l'otan qui affirme
le soutien des pays de l'organisation
nous sommes conscients que la turquie
supporter un une charge importante mais
il faut trouver des termes des solutions
durables à cette crise je suis très
préoccupé par ce qui s'est passé lors
frontière turque récemment les flux
migratoires sont un défi qui nécessite
des solutions
j'accueille donc un dialogue entre la
turquie et l'union européenne
et j'espère que l'on pourra trouver un
moyen d'avancer
l'otan continuera à jouer son rôle
les nuits seront déjà pour résoudre la
crise migratoire les alliés sont
également prêts à continuer à soutenir
la turquie et nous explorons d'autres
façons de le faire et le porte parole du
ministère allemand des affaires
étrangères s'est exprimé cet après midi
il est catégorique il ne laissera pas la
turquie faire du chantage à l'union
européenne
ce n'est pas notre impression que la
turquie ne veuille pas d'autres soutiens
de l'union européenne
bien au contraire nous avons
l'impression que la turquie est
intéressé par d'autres mesures de
soutien et des discussions ont lieu
aujourd'hui à bruxelles à ce sujet entre
le président turc et madame von der
leyen et nous sommes prêts à y
participer de manière constructive c'est
un soutien supplémentaire s'avère
nécessaire
en même temps il est clair que nous ne
nous laisserons pas faire de chantage
ce que nous recherchons c'est une
répartition équitable de la charge
la turquie fait beaucoup de choses et
nous sommes prêts à la soutenir mais
cela n'est possible qu ensemble dans le
cadre d'une coopération qui devrait
avoir lieu aujourd'hui à bruxelles et
les réfugiés sur place attendent
toujours de savoir leur prochaine
destination mais ils ne perdent pas
espoir on écoute certains d'entre eux
peut repartir en afghanistan nous avons
en ennemi là bas les talibans
envoyer des menaces de mort on ne peut
pas repartir en afghanistan s'ils
n'ouvrent pas les frontières
je passerai également nous avons bon
espoir
nous sommes là grâce à notre espoir on
ne pourrait pas y arriver sans espoir et
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales étaient sur notre
plateau tout à l'heure pour lui l'union
européenne pourrait débloquer davantage
de fonds pour aider la turquie à gérer
ces flux migratoires l'union européenne
à des moyens beaucoup plus diversifiée
que l'otan elle n'a pas de moyens
militaires mais elle a des moyens
diverses et variées d'abord un budget
avec des fonds est peut-être possible
d'augmenter les fonds qui avaient été
alloués à la turquie 6 6 milliards
d'euros pour s'occuper des 300 et
quelques 300 une 2d des 3 millions
pardon de réfugiés qui se trouvent
actuellement en turquie
on a parlé d'une somme peut être de 500
millions d'euros qui pourrait s'ajouter
aux 6 milliards décidé en 2000 celles
qui n'ont d'ailleurs pas été
complètement débourser il est certain
que madame von der leyen comme monsieur
comme le président du conseil européen
vont lui expliquer qu'il n'est pas
question de recevoir des masses de
réfugiés à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne que d'ailleurs on a très bien
vu que ça avait un effet de en politique
intérieure immédiat qui était de faire
monter les parties les partis anti
européens dans les états membres que par
conséquent ça n'est pas une politique
qui pourrait être suivi
on les trouve américaine commence à se
retirer d'afghanistan alors
qu'aujourd'hui un nouvel attentat
revendiqué par le groupe etat islamique
a visé le palais présidentiel à kaboul
deux explosions au moment où ashraf
ghani et son opposant d'où la doula
organisaient des cérémonies
d'investiture concurrente des détails
avec grégoire douce et
deux explosions en plein discours le
président sortant achraf rani d'un côté
et son grand rival le chef de l'exécutif
abdullah abdullah de l'autre se déclare
alors tous deux présidents deux
cérémonies qui ont lieu au sein du même
palais présidentiel nous avons vu des
attaques plus importantes
n'ayez pas peur les deux explosions ne
paniquez pas asseyez-vous lors de notre
campagne pour l'élection nous avions
promis au peuple que nous n'accepterions
aucun gouvernement résultant d'une
fraude et nous tenons notre promesse une
véritable cacophonie politique est un
événement qui plonge un peu plus
l'afghanistan dans une crise
institutionnelle qui à près de six mois
le scrutin présidentiel donne lieu à des
résultats incertains annoncé de manière
définitive bien plus tard au mois de
février après seize mille cinq cents
plaintes pour irrégularités
selon la commission électorale achraf
rani obtient 52 64 % des suffrages
son principal opposant abdullah abdullah
termine second ce dernier qualifié alors
les résultats de trahison nationale
l'attaqué terroriste de ce lundi est la
deuxième depuis l'accord entre les états
unis et les talibans signé le 29 février
un pacte qui prévoit entre autres le
retrait sous 14 mois des troupes
étrangères une situation politique
confuse analysées par le spécialiste du
moyen-orient
david rigoulet roze c'est le résultat
des élections qui est contesté donc on
retrouve une situation propre ou
similaire à celle de 2014 avec les mêmes
les mêmes protagonistes à savoir ashraf
ghani et abdullah abdullah
les deux ont décidé de faire
effectivement une cérémonie
d'investiture le paradoxe est que ça se
fait dans deux ailes différentes du même
palais présidentiel à kaboul donc c'est
assez paradoxal mais effectivement c'est
le signe d'une division profonde de
l'exécutif
argan et ça n'augure rien de bon par
rapport à une étape ultérieure qui était
un
prévue dans le cadre de l'accord signé
avec les talibans entre les américains
et à libon à doha à savoir le dialogue
offre un terreau afghans qu'ils
demanderaient effectivement un exécutif
au moins homogène une crise qui
intervient alors que d'importants
pourparlers doivent avoir lieu ce mardi
entre les insurgés des autorités de
kaboul l'opposition et la société civile
jusqu'à ce jour les talibans refuse de
reconnaître la légitimité du
gouvernement afghan et on écoute
l'analyse d'emmanuel dupuy président de
l'institut prospective et sécurité en
europe il revient sur les différents
épisodes de cette confusion politique le
processus électoral a été très compliqué
avec un certain nombre de violences qui
ont émaillé ce processus qui ont empêché
d'avoir un certain nombre de résultats
deuxièmement il ya eu des contestations
elles portent sur l'ensemble des votes
avec là aussi faut-il le rappeler un
pourcentage très faible moins de 10% des
neuf millions d'électeurs se sont
déclarés faso sont présentés au scrutin
pour des raisons de sécurité que
j'évoquais précédemment
et donc cette contestation du reste a
toujours lieu puisque le premier
ministre le chef de l'exécutif
abdullah ben de la part du principe que
tous les votes n'ont pas été recomptées
et la marge de manoeuvre telle qu'elle a
été annoncée
assez rapidement par le président élu
est donc investi aujourd'hui ashraf
ghani ne porte que sur douze mille voix
on sait avec un certain nombre de
précautions que le président shafran y
est prêt à faire un gouvernement d'union
nationale avec une large part au camp
adverse donc de son adversaire abdullah
abdullah 30 à 40% du gouvernement mais
avec une détermination et donc une
certitude de ne pas avoir d' où l'
abdullah être de nouveau dans la même
configuration qu'en 2014
le sipri l'institut international de
recherche pour la paix vient de dévoiler
son tout dernier rapport concernant les
ventes d'armes dans le monde sans
surprise des états unis sont les plus
gros vendeurs de matériel d'armement sur
la planète loin devant la russie et la
france
l'hexagone qui connaît néanmoins une
dynamique impressionnante en la matière
thomas boni quand les tensions
géopolitiques sont de plus en plus
fortes et nombreuses il y en a qui se
frotte les mains ce sont les fabricants
et les vendeurs d'armes sur la période
analysée par le sipri c'est-à-dire de
2015 à 2019 les affaires sont plutôt
bonnes le commerce mondial des armes a
connu une croissance de 5 et demi pour
cent par rapport à la période précédente
de 2010 à 2014
les plus gros exportateurs d'armes dans
le monde sans trop de surprise ce sont
les américains avec désormais 36 % de
part de marché la russie est deuxième
avec 21 % et la france complète ce
podium avec pas loin de 8% au-delà de ce
classement ce qui est intéressant c'est
de relever les dynamiques en cours
ainsi les états unis ont gagné des parts
de marché à linverse de la russie dont
les ventes ont reculé ces dernières
années mais la hausse la plus notable
concerne la france ces cinq dernières
années
l'hexagone a enregistré une augmentation
de ses ventes d'armes à hauteur de 72%
avec 7 9 % des parts du marché mondial
la france passe donc de la 5e à la 3e
place de ce classement est atteint un
record d'exportation d'armements datant
de 1990 cette augmentation fait suite
aux efforts continus du gouvernement
français pour promouvoir les
exportations d'armes
l'industrie française a bénéficié des
commandes de l'egypte du qatar et de
l'inde
maintenant qu'on sait qui vend les armes
penchons nous sur les acheteurs de ces
blindés frégates et autres sous marins
plus d'un tiers des armes importées le
sont par des pays du moyen-orient
le plus gros importateur est sans
conteste l'arabie saoudite avec 12% du
total des importations d'armes sur la
planète
là encore ce qui est notable c'est la
dynamique de cette proportion ryad a
acheté 130 % d'armes de plus que sur la
période précédente par son rapport le
sipri est un institut de recherche sur
la paire regrette ces flux d'armes vers
des pays en conflit
vendre des armes à l'arabie saoudite ou
aux émirats arabes unis alors même que
ces deux pays mènent une guerre au yémen
cela avait provoqué des remous
importants dans l'opinion notamment en
europe
l'allemagne a ainsi mis en place un
embargo sur ses exportations vers ryad
alors que dans le même temps emmanuel
macron dit assumer la vente d'armes
françaises à l'arabie saoudite
la bonne santé du secteur de l'armement
c'est un succès parfois difficile à
défendre ce qui est bon pour l'économie
ne l'est pas forcément dans la
perception de l'opinion publique
un dilemme qui risquent de se présenter
à nouveau dans les prochaines années
le sipri estime que les exportations
d'armes françaises ne devraient pas
baisser significativement durant les
cinq prochaines années et c'est la fin
de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
prochaine édition demain matin 7 heures
du matin heure française
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est
[Musique]
l'huile de palme est l'un des produits
les plus controversées de notre temps
c'est une graisse végétale solide et
elle est très bon marché
en 2017 la production a atteint un
sommet de 63 millions de tonnes cette
croissance rapide de la demande globale
d'huile peu coûteuse a causé une
expansion massive des plantations de
palmiers à huile
ce qui entraîne à son tour la
destruction de la forêt tropicale
[Musique]
dans la seule indonésie plus de dix
millions d'hectares de forêts primaires
ont été détruits et cela se poursuit
[Musique]
que veut-il dire en japonais qui comme
henry lors il veut dire qu'il ne sort
pas de chez soi tout simplement le
propre du phénomène hikikomori c'est que
on trouve des jeunes au japon qui refuse
de sortir de chez eux alors qu'eux ils
n'ont pas de pathologie identifiée dans
la nomenclature psychiatriques
aujourd'hui l'équipe maureen sont pas
des fadas de jeux vidéo c'est pas des
gens qui passent tout leur temps dans
leur chambre scotché à l'ordinateur à
jouer aux jeux vidéo et c'est un
documentaire qui permet de comprendre en
quoi ce phénomène est vraiment
spécifique de la culture japonaise au
japon la pression scolaire est
extrêmement forte
mais les parents s'endettent souvent à
vie pour que leurs enfants fassent des
études et puis vous savez au moment de
la crise d'adolescence un bel quelque
chose qui est remis en question
c'est une super méga crise d'adolescence
considérablement majorait par la
situation économique culturel social
familial qui lie aux japon
fact et les chaussants homme qu'est ce
qui vous a décidé à quitter votre emploi
à plein temps pour devenir blogueurs et
agriculteurs c'était dur bien sûr mais
nous l'avons fait 0 0
aujourd'hui nous allons répondre à vos
questions
c'était frustrant ne savez pas par où
commencer
je ne sais pas vraiment comment ça va
marcher
quel cauchemar
je sais que c'était un idéaliste dont
mais il n'y avait pas d'autres
possibilités
oui ça a été la sas mon chéri diffuser
sa vie sur internet c'est effrayant
terrifiant même wise
tu vas me faire pleurer aussi plus on a
dû travailler dur mais notre rêve est
devenu réalité
c'est comme une télé réalité être et la
vie
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
cet écho positif n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui compte c'est qu'on soit vient
des guignols
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extraits
dans un musée tous les témoins de notre
époque sont dans la grande interview
bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches
l'émission qui s'adresse à tous même à
ceux qui ne savent pas compter jusqu'à 5
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler de la 5g
bonjour hostel bonjour olivier bonjour à
tous bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode de
ses cages c'est la prochaine évolution
en matière de télécommunications après
la 4g que nous utilisons aujourd'hui la
5g est à nos portes qu'est ce que la 5g
va changer dans nos quotidiens quelle
différence par rapport à la 4g
quelles perspectives économiques la
singer va-t-elle nous offrir ce sont des
questions que nous allons à nous poser
aujourd'hui avec vous olivier mais pour
commencer qu'est ce que la 5g comment ça
marche et que va-t-elle changer dans
notre quotidien le point avec le tiroir
cash d'antoine basse la 5g sega
cinquième génération de réseaux mobiles
jusqu'à 100 fois plus rapides que notre
actuel 4g la promesse d'une quasi
instantanéité lors d'une connexion
concrètement cela ouvre à la traduction
simultanée
la multiplication des objets
interconnecté où l'avenir de la
robotique
vous pourrez peut-être bientôt regarder
ses cages dans une telle définition que
vous pourrez voir jusqu'où petit cheveu
du crâne d'olivier de la marche
qu'est ce qu'un temps
tiens pas extra mais pas l'argent et
déroule à eau et tu veux dire que
l'europe c'est pour les cours et après
que des oled ces deux années là 5 g
passe par des ondes à haute fréquence
peu utilisé jusqu'à présent
essentiellement par l'armée mais qui
vont être ré attribuées aux opérateurs
plus la fréquence des ondes est haute
plus avec son rapide mais moins leur
surface d'émission est large forçant
donc la multiplication des antennes
relais pour leur diffusion
selon une étude du cabinet ihs hs markit
la 5g pourrait rapporter 3600 milliards
de dollars et 22,3 millions d'emplois
dans le monde d'ici 2035
en france ce serait 124 milliards de
dollars et 448 mille emplois et naturel
alors 446 mis en place vous oubliez que
j ai déjà tâté études prévoient la
croissance qu'on va avant l'année
prochaine alors passé même pas de ces
chiffres sont exacts se pose aussi la
question d'un éventuel danger pour la
santé
l' agence nationale de sécurité
sanitaire a pointé dans un